Guten Morgen Horst.
Wenn ich hier nicht meinen Willen kriege trete ich bin drei Tagen zurück.
Nee ich trete vor niemanden zurück.
Der Sieg ist mein.
Hast du schon genug.
Jetzt hör mal auf du abgebrochener Riese du hast keine Arme mehr.
Das ist nur ein Kratzer ich spuck dir ins Auge und Blende dich.
Na du bist doch nur ein armer Irrer.
Gut einigen wir uns auf Unentschieden.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 260 vom vom 6. Juli 2018 und wir sind.
Hilus und hin und sie haben ein Gast.
Wir haben heute einen Gast und sag mir heute auch mal eine Sendung mal angekündigt mach mir Aldi sonst nicht.
Der CCC hatte Sendung angekündigt freundlicherweise ja.
Genau hat mich nur zeigen und der Publikation Zwang geschickt genau unser Gast ist Moritz Moritz Bartl Hallo Moritz.
Ja wir haben ich ja eingeladen und wir werden dann auch gleich
ausführlich sprechen über dieses ganze Tohuwabohu womit Hausdurchsuchungen Anschuldigungen und anderen Auswirkungen
die es gab rund um den Verein zwiebelfreunde e.v. um einen Aufruf zu einer vielleicht Krawalle orientierten Demo und all diesen ganzen Kram
aber das etwas ausführlicher behandeln werden, glaube ich auch erstmal unsere.
Anderen Themen durch aber wir können bereits durchaus die Gelegenheit geben sich kurz vorzustellen.
Genau bist du denn.
Ja ich bin der Moritz ich bin mit Gründer von so einem Verein der beschäftigt sich mit angemietet und,
sicherer Kommunikation und solchen Dingen der nennt sich zwiebelfreunde das kommt vom onion Routing von Tor Browser Tor das benutzt ja auch nie dorthin als Verfahren
und da erlebt man so einige Dinge über die Jahre gegründet 2011 und jetzt eben vor
knapp über zwei Wochen gab es großflächige Durchsuchungen unsere Vorstände unsere Vereinsräume und unserem Hackerspace in Augsburg,
und da können wir dann noch mal ausführlich eingehen.
Genau wo du bist jetzt freundlicherweise hier nach Berlin gekommen dass wir uns hier dann auch mal intensiv mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen können weil es hat
auch alles ein bisschen Dimensionen über über den eigentlichen Fall hinaus wie wir finden und im Anschluss ist ja nun auch schon wieder so einiges passiert was hier diskussionswürdig ist aber,
jetzt, erstmal zu den guten Nachrichten.
Die gute Nachricht ist es gibt gute Nachricht die ja die upload-filter
und das Leistungsschutzrecht haben es nicht durch das EU-Parlament geschafft erinnert euch an mehrere Sendungen bei denen Julia Reda bei uns
zugeschaltet war und über den aktuellen Stand berichtet hat wir hatten jetzt gestern am 5. Juli war die Abstimmung im EU-Parlament wo also der,
Entwurf des Rechtsausschusses in das Parlament getragen wurde
mit der Bitte um Zustimmung das handelt sich dabei um ein üblicherweise als Formalie behandelt.
Bei dem ist nach meiner Kenntnis noch nicht vorgekommen ist wahrscheinlich werde ich dir den Kommentaren korrigiert werden aber nach meiner Kenntnis ist es noch nicht vorgekommen das sind einer solchen Situation das Parlament sich nicht
der Ausschuss Meinung anschließt und gestern wurde mit.
Einer Mehrheit von 318 zu 278 Stimmen bei 31 Enthaltungen die Entscheidung,
gegen diesen Entwurf gefällt das heißt der,
Axel Forster Berichterstatter aus dem Rechtsausschuss dafür wird mit seinem Entwurf wieder zurückgehen müssen julia hatte also zurück
in Neuplanung gehen müssen einen neuen Anlauf machen müssen damit den kritischen Augen unter die kritischen Augen des EU Parlamentes zu treten um eine EU Copyright Reform
durchzuführen.
Fand es ziemlich bemerkenswert wie die Abstimmung
ausgegangen ist nicht nur jetzt rein vom Ergebnis her selbst ob man diese Enthaltungen noch mit als Gegenstimmen rechnen würde hätte die Mehrheit gereicht dagegen vorzugehen
ich fand es auch bemerkenswert wieder darüber berichtet wurde weil die Abstimmung war ja nicht gegen diese kleinen Details die wir hier primär kritisiert haben und ja der,
Grund für die Aufregung mit den Widerstand war also die upload-filter das Leistungsschutzrecht trotzalledem wurde es danach auch in den Medien so transportiert ich weiß ich kann und wir sollen
U-Bahnhof an und auf der großflächigen displaced Parlament stimmt gegen upload-filter rein technisch betrachtet haben sie das nicht getan weil sie haben gegen das Gesamtpaket,
bestimmt aber es ist glaube ich relativ klar dass vor allem die upload-filter und in gewisser Hinsicht auch das Leistungsschutzrecht hier der Knackpunkt sind und nicht,
schätze mal so jetzt Julia noch mal fragen würden,
damit ist das Ding politisch mindestens angeschlagen wenn ich sogar komplett tot weil es einfach nicht absehbar ist dass man,
mit diesen Instrumentarien auch den zweiten Durchlauf schaffen würde und natürlich möchte das Parlament das reformierte Urheberrechtsgesetz noch in dieser Legislaturperiode durch.
Spannend ist der sich ja alles noch zu Wort gemeldet hat ja also,
Kaiser hatte dann irgendwie so einen Komponistin der da auf drei Seiten einfach nur noch gewarnt hat dass das ja wohl überhaupt nicht sein können und und die Urheber müssen geschützt werden und und so weiter und
man hat an dieser Debatte wie an so vielen gesehen dass da jetzt nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr an der Sache diskutiert wird ne da steht jetzt kommen weitere Vorndran und haben die Rechteverwerter oder,
kein dieser Aspekte irgendeiner Kritik mal irgendwie sinnvollen Raum gelassen und muss man auch zum Schutz von Julia Reda immer wieder betonen sie sagt jedes mal mit ihr darüber gesprochen haben hat sie gesagt
als allererstes möchte ich feststellen das Urheberrecht wie es in dieser Form es ist
Mist und es braucht eine Urheberrechtsverletzung nur nicht diese Artikel 11 und 13 also upload-filter und Leistungsschutzrechte drin haben weil die erwiesenermaßen Unsinn sind und.
Nein sie haben sie diese dieser Dachverband der Musikindustrie hat er dann sogar noch einen offenen Brief von Paul McCartney an das EU-Parlament irgendwie rausgeholt wo ich auch dachte jetzt
jetzt geht's aber runter dann hat dieser achselfurz sich im wie beklagt er wäre die ganze Zeit beleidigt worden.
Und und und dann hat er noch irgendwie geschrieben ist handele sich um eine Fake News Kampagne also irgendwie so eine so eine trumpsche,
samshield Meuterei auf der Bounty Nummer da irgendwie aufgeführt unglaublich wie das Ding da geführt wurde einfach nur unter Dominik ganz einfach mal sagen.
Weil sich hier einer einer sinnvollen Auseinandersetzung mit dem Thema ganz einfach verwehrt wurde und das war nun mal dieser Axel Post und nicht,
diejenigen die hier dafür gesorgt haben mit großer Mühe noch mal ratio in diesem Prozess zu bringen wir haben als TTC auch noch mal eine Pressemitteilung dazu veröffentlicht weil dann ja auch noch irgendwie also der Aspekt der mir so unter,
betrachtet Jean war wer soll diese upload-filter überhaupt bereitstellen kann am Ende gibt's nur wenige Unternehmen die das,
die überhaupt über sinnvoll funktionieren upload-filter verfügen also Facebook und Google und das ist ja im Prinzip nur denen,
nutzen würde wenn nun jeder andere kleinste platform alle ihre Inhalte einmal durch den Filter schicken müsste er das heißt der will ja quasi die müssten die müssten dann ihre diese Konkurrenten nicht mehr kaufen sondern würden diese deren Inhalte quasi kostenlos frei Haus in in,
Tiere Filter bekommen und dann waren da noch irgendwelche EU-Parlament Heidi in allen Ernstes noch vertreten haben,
diese Copyright Reform würde nun nun ausgerechnet endlich,
Facebook und Google in in ihre Grenzen weisen das ist wirklich.
Hanebüchen Filter.
Hanebüchen gewesen oder muss man auch mal loben loben und wie wendet man das fordern und fördern,
Dorothee Bär weiße der Netzpolitiker aus der CDU CSU Fraktion wie Thomas Jarzombek Peter Tauber
Tankred Schipanski Nadine schön haben dann noch einen Brief an die konservative EVP-Fraktion im EU-Parlament geschrieben haben gesagt bitte bitte bitte,
wir halten die Kritik von SPD und FDP an diesem Ding aufrecht ja das heißt dann die die deutschen Konservativen dann noch den.
Den Europäischen konservativen Satz bitte bitte bitte,
denke nach denke nach und dass all das zusammen alle diese Stimmen der Ratio
die jetzt nicht nur damit geredet haben das jetzt unbedingt die armen Künstler in Nebelschütz sein müssen kostet es was es wolle sondern die gesagt haben diese beiden Artikel so nicht,
Amir gesiegt und ich feiere ein Triumph europäischer Debattenkultur über,
Axel Voss.
Ausgewählte Paul McCartney ich meine wenn man jetzt versucht auf will das EU-Parlament auch wirklich sind mit Import von Briten gut aber ich meine.
Ludwig Ende hin dass die meisten Ledersitzen kennen.
Retardiert ist jetzt eh bald raus also wird schon was anderes bringen müssen alles ausgeredet alte Briten.
Der arme will also ich bin ja eigentlich ein Gelände ich schätze Paul McCartney ja.
Über solange er sinkt also da kann er meinetwegen gerne das Maul aufmachen aber so rein politisch hat irgendwie nicht so ganz ich finde es auch mal wieder so unfassbar dass also immer diese permanente Behauptung die Urheber würden nicht geschützt werden,
also wenn irgendetwas wirklich über alle Maßen auf diesem Planeten geschützt wird dann sind Urheber ja wo er hier war echt noch der der Paul McCartney noch mal so lange muss noch mal solange
tot sein wir jetzt alt ist und dann verfällt überhaupt erstmal sein Urheberrecht.
Da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher ob das verfällt da wäre ich weg.
Also stand heute ja.
Da wäre ich mir wirklich nicht so sicher ob das Urheberrecht von von Lennon McCartney jemals irgendwo verfallen wird.
Naja gut das meine einzige Kampf ist ja immer Micky Maus so weil da wär's dann einen.
Bei Micky Maus halt älter.
Soweit genau also wir werden sehen soweit ist es auf jeden Fall mal gute Nachrichten.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch an Julia Räder und alle die sich da
für engagiert haben Andy save you Internet Kampagne Andi Wiki Media Foundation die sich da eingebracht hat viel zu viel und jetzt hier alle zu zählen da hat er noch eine change.org
org Petition DMV ruckzuck 750 000 Unterschriften hatte alle die sich da engagiert haben
herzlichen Glückwunsch und.
Genau auch alle Hörerinnen und Hörer von Logbuch Netzpolitik die dann hier vielleicht hatte Dich unsere cuse mal aufnehmen und dann,
bewegen es kann dann doch noch mal was bringen jetzt ist die Sache also die Kuh ist noch nicht vom Eis
aber es ist zumindest davon auszugehen dass ich die Bedingungen hier komplett geändert haben ich freue mich auch ob irgendwie Herr Voss in seiner Rolle verbleibt aber die sind jetzt wahrscheinlich erstmal nicht so ohne weiteres rauskicken aber wir wissen es nicht.
Ja dann kommen wir noch zu unserem.
Komme wieder zu schlechten Nachricht.
Immer wieder zu.
Also tschuldigung für diesen kleinen Werbeblock diesen kleinen überhaupt nicht reinpassen und Block positive Neuigkeiten.
Moritz es ist jetzt etwas über zwei Wochen her da hat bei dir die Tierärzte die an der Tür geklingelt zwar lass mich raten sechs uhr morgens.
Ja kurz nach 6 Uhr ich habe ab 5 Uhr dürfen sie rechtlich kurz nach 6 Uhr klingelt es unten an der Tür und wir haben erstmal gedacht dass das sind schon wieder irgendwelche Chaoten von dem Club der da in der Nähe ist
oder irgendwelche Schulkinder hat die Klingel auch mal ganz gerne auf dem Weg haben dann ebenso eine Gesamtschule
und habe erstmal die Klingel ausgesteckt werden so eine Funkklingel die kann man bequemen einfach deaktivieren und haben uns wieder ins Bett gelegt und,
dann hat sie ein paar Minuten gedauert und dann hat oben an der Tür geklingelt und zwar schon recht laut recht lange.
Dann habe ich mir doch mal Bademantel angezogen und bin zur Tür und habe gefragt wer da ist dann ist es Polizei wir haben Durchsuchungsbeschluss bitte machen Sie mal die Tür auf dann habe ich die Tür aufgemacht.
Dann hieß es doch mal kurz reinkommen wir zeigen Ihnen dann auch den Beschluss und ich so ja den hätte ich gerne jetzt hier gesehen und habe mir den dann so im Bademantel ohne irgendwas drunter erstmal an der Tür durchgelesen.
Und dann war mir eigentlich auch schon klar was da abläuft also wir haben uns ja als Verein vor allem deswegen gegründet weil wir Tor exit Infrastruktur betreiben also anonymisierungs Infrastruktur
und damals sehr viel nachgedacht und
vorbereitet auf das was passieren kann nämlich das irgendjemand über Tor.
Irgendwelche schlimmen Dinge tut und wir dann erst mal kurzfristig auf den Radar ja wandern von Ermittlungsbehörden
und haben uns eigentlich schon drauf eingestellt dass da irgendwann mal jemand vorbeikommen würde
dass das erst sieben Jahre später passiert und dass das dann auch gar nicht in Zusammenhang mit dem steht was wir damit Tor machen das haben wir so nicht erwartet aber jedenfalls habe ich mir schon irgendwie
gedacht okay ich wusste auch insofern über diese verschiedenen Vorträge die ich auch nur empfehlen kann,
auf die wir später glaube ich auch noch zu sprechen kommen wie man sich so verhält bei so einer Durchsuchung wir haben die dann erstmal rein gebeten wir haben den Kaffee angeboten
das waren sechs Leute die paar hatten krachen dabei aber nicht gezogen
und das hat sich auch für die glaube ich relativ schnell recht entspannt angefühlt weil ich jetzt nicht irgendwie angefangen habe und welche Granaten zu werfen oder sonstige Dinge zu tun,
und dann
finde es eben an also aus dem Beschluss geht hervor dass sie halt so verschiedene Unterlagen beschlagnahmen dürfen verschiedene elektronische Kommunikation
in und das steht auch schon so drin in Bezug auf unser Spendenkonto dass wir für rise up unterhalten und in Bezug auf einen mir bis dato unbekannten Blog.
Der Augsburg für krawalltouristen.
Ich glaube wir müssen rise-up vielleicht auch noch mal.
Also wir haben halt als zwiebelfreunde angefangen und haben unseren Verein gegründet um sichere Kommunikation im Internet zu unterstützen und dazu zählt eben nicht nur Tor sondern gibt's ja verschiedene
Dinge die man da so unterstützen kann und vor ein paar Jahren kamen wir mit,
den Leuten von rise up die in den USA so Infrastruktur betreiben VPN in Frösche
Tour e-mail address Struktur und so weiter ins Gespräch,
es denn nicht möglich wäre dass wir da so eine Partnerschaft eingehen für ein Spendenkonto in Europa,
und das machen wir seit einigen Jahren also leiser bietet kostenlos,
verschiedene Infrastruktur an von dem Pets Server über eben VPN E-Mail und so weiter ich weiß gar nicht was sie da alles inzwischen haben und
wir haben seitdem eben für Reise abwenden entgegengenommen wenn man auf Reis auf auf die Webseite geht und dort aufs Airport
dann findet man eben unter anderem neben den verschiedenen anderen Möglichkeiten der dem riseup Kollektiv Geld zukommen zu lassen ein Konto von uns.
Und bald euer Konto deshalb weil europäisches Konto ohne Gebühren aus Europa zu erreichen und der Verein ist gemeinnützig.
Richtig der Vereines gemeines gesagt heißt spenden können in den meisten europäischen Ländern steuerlich abgesetzt werden.
Und da die sichere Kommunikation zum Vereinszweck gehört könnt ihr dann eben an dieses
ebenfalls glaube ich absoluten nonprofit laufende Kollektiv rise up eben da diese finanzielle Unterstützung geben.
Also reiß ob in den USA hat eine gemeinnützige Organisation das ist so eine 50123 die nennt sich weiß applabs
die haben aber auch sozusagen so einen kommerziellen Zweck aber das ist sozusagen Details von Gemeinnützigkeitsrecht wir unterstützen dort nicht den Betrieb von der an e-mail Infrastruktur also die Gelder die wir für rise
Einwerben das sind unsere Gelder
geben dir dann in Absprache mit denen aus wir haben z.b. trees finanziert trees ist ein super geiles Plugin für Dovecot für den IMAP server,
das eingehende Mails so verschlüsselt dass sie im im Normalbetrieb auch nicht vom Serverbetreiber gelesen werden können,
sondern nur in dem Moment wo ich per IMAP mein Konto abrufe und mein Passwort sozusagen über Mittel für diesen IMAP Login wird das Deutsch unlocked
und meine Mails mir übergeben von meinem IMAP-Konto und die Entwicklung von der Software zum bedibuy weiß ob im Einsatz ist produktiv das haben wir mitfinanziert.
Cavalier projektbezogen arbeiten müssen nicht klappt natürlich und dann könnt ihr müsst jetzt jedes einzelne Projekt sagen dieses Projekt hat den Vereinszweck and entsprochen ja klar leuchtet,
das finde ich ja sehr schön dieses Plugin sich mir verlinken wir bitte weil das nicht für ich kenne eine e-mail Server der ist gebrauchen könnte.
Wie heißt das noch mal.
Trees ich gebe euch die Ohren an.
Okay und jetzt fragt man sich aber natürlich wie kommen die denn jetzt von einem Spendenkonto für rise up auf den Gedanken bei dir vor der Tür zu stehen und wie wir feststellen ja nicht nur bei dir.
Also ich wusste zu dem Zeitpunkt nichts das Wasser parallel auch noch Durchsuchungen in anderen Städten liefen er ich habe es mir aber schon gedacht weil wir hatten nämlich damals bei Vereinsgründung mit Anwälten durchgesprochen wieso was ablaufen wird,
und das ist eben bei Vereinen so gehandhabt wird das zeitgleich am Vereinssitz durchsucht wird und bei allen Vorständen,
das war eigentlich davon mal auszugehen das heißt ich habe mir schon gedacht dass das gerade jetzt parallel läuft das haben die mir nicht so gesagt natürlich während das bei mir lief
es war auch relativ einfach weil bei mir zu Hause keinerlei Unterlagen sind weil wir haben halt einen Finanzer der hat die finanzfunktion der hat die ganzen Mitglieder Unterlagen Kontounterlagen und so weiter
und das habe ich denen so auch mitgeteilt ich war auch,
sehr gewillt daran beizutragen zu der Aufklärung das eben weder wir noch irgendwie weiter mit
diesen krawalltouristen Block irgendwie in Verbindung stehen außer das eben und das haben sie mir glaube ich schon dann mitgeteilt,
das eben dieser Augsburg für krawalltouristen Blog ein Impressum hatte ich find das ja schon sehr lustig dass die diese Sektion auf
auf der Website Impressum nennen auf der eine advisor net E-Mail-Adresse genannt wird,
gut dann habe ich gesagt Klages.
Stand da auch nicht also es weiß keinen.
Na ja da war noch so komische binäre und ASCII-Zeichen drunter zu den ich dann später am Freitag drauf auch noch intensiv befragt wurde da war immer so ein Public Key cheap.
Die sie für dich gefragt was damit was ist das.
Ja ja die wollten von mir.
Na ja da ging es dann darum ob sozusagen welche technische Expertise hinter einem solchen Block stehen muss wie wie meine Einschätzung ist dass das sozusagen hoch ausgebildete,
Menschen sind oder ich habe den dann erklärt das gibt auch für Outlook Plugins und dass das teilweise in Firmen Kontexten eingesetzt.
Duden nachgeholfen das Hirse.
Jaja na ja klar also ich meine das war ja schon auch in meinem Interesse zusagen oder in unserem Interesse zu sagen es gibt natürlich die Wahl ich hätte da aber Haupt nichts mehr sagen können aber,
dass das würde ich auch so machen das ist ja auch das was man immer hört und empfohlen bekommt dass man eben nichts aussagt ohne Anwalt in dem Fall aber da können wir auch später noch mal zum sprechen kommen also jedenfalls lief dann bei uns die Durchsuchung.
Ich würd ich würd erstmal noch ganz kurz also damit wir hier den Faden nicht verlieren ne
es gibt eine Seite Augsburg für krawalltouristen. Noblogs.org soll die Polizei interessiert sich für diese Webseite diese Webseite hat als Inhalt.
Den Eistee Bundesparteitag am 30.06 17 2008
angreifen und veröffentlicht dort ein Inhalt mit dem Titel Augsburg Aufruf zum Krawall in dem hier eben Vorschläge gemacht werden,
wo man als krawalltourist in Augsburg Sehenswürdigkeiten findet,
die Polizei entscheidet sich also nun aus welchem Grund auch immer Anstoß an dieser Seite zu finden ich glaube wahrscheinlich weil die AFD diese Seite angezeigt hat.
Darüber weiß ich nicht im Detail.
Okay das war also eine reine Spekulation und jetzt kommt also die Polizei nicht in Augsburg sondern die Staatsanwaltschaft in München.
Generalstaatsanwalt.
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft in München.
Da habe ich auch später gelernt dass die sich beschäftigt eben vor allem mit organisierter Kriminalität und Terrorismus.
Das heißt das war noch nicht mal die Staatsanwaltschaft jetzt in Augsburg nee das ist noch eine Eskalationsstufe drüber.
So die dicht also quasi die höchste Kompetenz der Strafverfolgung die das Land Bayern zur Verfügung hat.
Besuch diese Seite und sagt impressum,
und im Impressum findet sie den Text zu früh gefreut wer wir sind verraten wir natürlich nicht,
trotzdem könnt ihr uns eine E-Mail schreiben wenn ihr Fragen Kritik Lob oder Ergänzungen für uns hat gerne könnt ihr uns auch Information Bilder Termin und so weiter von euren Aktionen gegen den AFD Bundesparteitag 2018 senden wir verbreiten diese gerne weiter,
schreib uns einfach eine E-Mail an Augsburg - für - krawalltouristen riseup.net,
ach ja und vergiss nicht die Verschlüsselung und darunter eben dieser PGP Block des heißt die die die die Speerspitze der Ermittlungsbehörden in Bayern sagt dann auf was ist denn dieses riseup.net.
Und landet bei einem bei all diesen E-Mail und sonstige Haus den Struktur anbieten im Kollektiv in den USA.
E-Mail Listen Chat VPN und Security bieten sie an.
Und dann finden Sie unter bautas donate irgendwann euch.
Genau also da gibt's von der Support aus Seite da ist ein Haufen Zeug gelistet wie man denen gutes zugute kommen lassen kann und da ist unter anderem unser Konto das damit auftaucht.
Dann haben sie messerscharf geschlussfolgert damit müsste er ja wohl ganz viel zu tun haben wenn ihr das finanziell unterstützt dann ist das ja quasi so wie Finanzierung einer Terror platform so einfachen Denkweise nachvollzogen.
Ja also dieser Durchsuchungsbeschluss enthält unter anderem dass sie sich natürlich dafür interessieren ob wir irgendwelche Nutzerdaten oder Protokolldaten oder Bestandsdaten zu
stehenden Accounts dieser krawalltouristen haben ich wurde auch gefragt ob wir spenden von den krawalltouristen erhalten haben was ich ja schon interessant finde weil,
wie soll ich das dann feststellen steht da dann hallo von den krawalltouristen im Überweisungszweck oder sowas ich konnte das aber auch nicht beantworten insbesondere deswegen weil ich halt eben
nicht jetzt tagesaktuell verfolge was auf diesem Konto so einen geht an Geldern aber sie haben halt gedacht okay wir haben vielleicht auch mit dem Betrieb was zu tun und das ist ja nicht völlig abwegig wenn man jetzt sagt ok da gibt es ein deutsches Spendenkonto auf der Seite
dass man vielleicht erstmal davon ausgeht.
Dass ihr da auch mehr.
Dass wir auch irgendwie mit der Infrastruktur zu tun haben.
Haben wir nicht und es ist auch auf unserer Webseite zwiebelfreunde de eigentlich auch klar so formuliert die Beamten haben mir auch gegenüber gesagt dass sie sich Vorträge von uns angeschaut haben
das ist sich die Garzeiten angeschaut am und so weiter die waren sehr gut informiert und haben eigentlich auch gleich,
sozusagen dieser Story die ich den erzählt habe nämlich das mit dem Spendenkonto und dass wir mit der Infrastruktur nicht zu tun haben,
davon sind die sogar schon ausgegangen also das fand ich schon so ein interessanten Part von von diesen Gesprächen während der Durchsuchung
dass die eben eigentlich durchaus Bescheid wussten ich meine wir wir sind ja nicht in WE geheimes organisierte Kriminalität Kollektiv sondern,
sage ich alles dokumentiert.
Warum kommen die denn dann trotzdem und rennen dir die Tür ein.
Naja also Tür eintreten war nicht das auch nicht rein rennen das war schon alles sehr zivile wie das abgelaufen ist ich denke mir also einmal
ich denke das wäre anders abgelaufen wenn jetzt dieser zwiebelfreunde e.v. Vorstände hätte wohl keiner davon in Augsburg lebt
also es gab halt diese zufällige Korrelation dass ich in Augsburg wohne,
und dann kann ich mir schon vorstellen dass man da im rheinboard dann sieht man diese noblogs.org das ist autistici inventati in Italien,
irgendwie Server in Argentinien und den USA und dass sie dann bei rise up die sitzen in den USA die haben ja auch später gesagt,
dass das mit so Rechtshilfeabkommen alles so kompliziert und es würde alles zu lange dauern also die waren ja in dem Druck dass sie gesagt haben ok der Parteitage steht an,
wir müssen das vorher noch klären am besten der Durchsuchungsbeschluss ist vom 14.06 bei mir waren sie am 20.06
dass du da daneben ja sozusagen so eine gewissen Ermittlungs Druck verspürt haben,
und dann eben zu sagen okay wir haben endlich daran Konto gefunden das in Deutschland ist und dann ist davon auch noch jemand aus dem Vorstand der in Augsburg lebt,
das muss eine heiße Spur sein da müssen wir so vorgehen und nicht einfach nur wie das üblich ist nach Bestandsdaten eben beim Provider anfragen.
Also das ist meine Erklärung wieso das so abgelaufen ist sie haben sich auch im Nachgang ich war dann noch mal zur Zeugenvernehmung am Freitag
nicht entschuldigt aber sie haben gekommen um Verständnis gebeten dass da aus politischer Seite und aus die besorgten Bürger die man immer so von denen man immer sowas hört dass es die.
Die dann da irgendwie anrufen und fragen warum ist denn dieser Blog immer noch online die Augsburger Allgemeine hatte da schon eine Serie zugemacht zu diesem krawalltouristen Block im Vorfeld und der bayerische Verfassungsschutz hat ja auch gesagt die gehen davon aus dass 2000 linksextreme nach.
Kommen es war der größte Polizeieinsatz seit dem Bestehen der Augsburger Polizei den die dafür den Parteitag aufgefahren haben.
Und war da irgendwas los.
Nein das war gar nichts los,
hatten einen einen ein Zelt eingerichtet wo sie die ganzen Leute ein knasten können die hat aber ein Richter auf Standby durchgehend von diesem Parteitag Samstag Sonntag 2001 aus 8 Bundesländer sind da
zusammengekommen ja das waren diese Links rechtsextreme nee.
Wie viele rechtsextreme waren in der wie viel Gewichte gehen Entzündungen.
Ich weiß nicht wie viele astella so.
Der fährt ja immer wieder das Problem dass die besucherlisten von ihren AFD verteilt Hagen dann immer irgendwo landen.
Ja da gab es ja noch diesen Gerke dazu bei einer Abstimmung ausversehen irgendwie viele ihre Hotelkarte benutzt haben zur Abstimmung und dass deswegen die Abstimmung wiederholt werden musste ich weiß nicht ob er das mitgekriegt hat.
Das war super geil aber das war so ungefähr das einzige was an diesem Wochenende wirklich passiert ist aber gut im Vorfeld gab es eben den bayerischen Verfassungsschutz der harter,
Informationen gehabt das eben 2000 krawalltouristen auch wirklich kommen werden die waren glaube ich alle auf der Fuzion.
Also der Tourismus wird ja in zunehmendem Maße in Problem also erst Asyl Tourismus.
Krawalltourist.
Und jetzt auch noch krawalltourismus Was kommt als nächstes.
Also es gibt ja auch so verschiedene Stimmen die sagen okay diese Webseite ich kann dir die zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht diese Webseite ist nicht von Leuten aus Augsburg erstellt das sind alles zusammen gegoogelte Informationen,
es gibt da durchaus stimmen die das auch sozusagen unter seiner Art false-flag betrachten gab es da nicht vielleicht eben,
Idee dass man sowas hochzieht um überhaupt dafür zu sorgen dass jetzt eben in der linken Ecke mal so durchgestöbert wird das sind alles Mutmaßung ich glaube dass es halt wirklich also so Augen also meine meinen Eindruck und meine Vermutung ist,
das ist eben durchaus Leute gibt die sagen kommt her hier gibt's kriegsdenkmäler die Erinnern an den Zweiten Weltkrieg,
und diese ganzen sozusagen Sachen kritisch beleuchten wollen
und Sarah muss man muss man jetzt sehen ob dann auch auf da und ob dein Aufruf zu Straftaten auf dieser Seite drauf ist ich kann den da durchaus als Laie so ein bisschen raus lesen,
also jedenfalls die sind da halt dagegen irgendwie aktiv geworden.
Also ich meine dass das ist doch erstmal für vollkommen unerheblich also ich bin so ein bisschen verwundert ne also mit dieser Seite hast du jetzt irgendwie nichts zu tun.
Diese und durchsuchen hat er nicht nur bei dir stattgefunden, ja nur zu sondern an fünf Orten insgesamt das ist hier eine riesige Polizeiaktion
von Leuten wo du sagst mir das den selber irgendwie ein bisschen klar ist dass sie da nach nach,
an der falschen Stelle suchen und das erinnert irgendwie ein also wohlwollend erinnert das an den Betrunkenen der seinen Schlüssel unter der Laterne sucht obwohl er genau weiß dass er den woanders verloren hat aber hier ist halt Licht.
Und ich weil ich will das ja sehr nett dass du ihn da auch ein bisschen den Zweifel im Zweifel auch zu gestehst aber nur mal diese Maßnahme der jetzt stattgefunden hat nicht nur bei dir
sondern auch bei weiteren Freunden von uns weiteren vorstellen und mitgliedern der zwiebelfreunde e.v. so
da können wir nichts für wenn die nicht klug genug sind für ihren Job.
Also ich meine das eine ist jetzt einfach liebt nur die psychologische Analyse sehe ich das jetzt mal zu sagen ok wie kams überhaupt
ob dazu weil man kann sich natürlich auch verschiedene Theorien jetzt mal so durchgehen warum sie das dann wirklich auch durchgezogen haben man kann auch verschiedene Theorien haben wie es überhaupt dazu kam aber von der einfach von der reinen psychologischen Analyse,
kann ich das soweit nachvollziehen denn noch natürlich ist es wie du schon sagst etwas krass und etwas dreist
und das würde ich dann aufseiten auch der Staatsanwaltschaft eben denen zu Last legen,
dass es da überhaupt gar keine Veranlassung aber soll ich mein wir existieren seit 2011 wir machen Vorträge wir wir gehen sogar irgendwie und bringen den Polizisten bei was dieses Darknet ist,
ich habe jetzt wieder eine Einladung zur International Police Association um dort an Vortrag zu geben und so weiter wir haben immer kooperiert ich mein das müssen die auch in ihren Datenbanken haben dass wir halt immer,
reagiert haben.
Kurier TV.
Den müssen wir noch mal erläutern.
Na ja gut das ist halt so dass wir natürlich diese anonymisierungs Infrastruktur betreiben und da kannst du immer mal wieder Anfragen die meisten kommen mit diesem Faxgerät fernruf Faxgerät
und dann die Kooperation die wir zeigen ist dass wir sehr schnell reagieren und sehr schnell Auskunft darüber geben dass wir keine Nutzerdaten haben,
weil wir das wieder auf rechtlicher Basis haben dürfen noch dürfen wir das sozusagen aber können wir das auf technischer Basis haben und das ist eine Kooperation das ist eine klare wir ignorieren solche Sachen nicht weg,
sondern wir reagieren auf und bieten auch jeweils an den Leuten das zu erklären und dienen entsprechende Schulungsmaßnahmen.
Nee aber das ist eh also ok schön und gut aber dass er letztendlich auch dass ein Eigeninteresse von euch damit ihr nicht jeden Tag nach Hausdurchsuchungen kommen ich,
damit wir uns vor Jahren unterhalten haben wo du mal irgendwie nur kurz gezeigt hast wie viele Anfragen da halt auch rein gekommen sind dass man da irgendwann mal eine Standard
Antwort hat die dann irgendwann auch mal freundlich und
eine Grundschule tauglich ist ist ja irgendwie auch klar das jetzt nicht jedes Mal neu schreibst sondern dass sie irgendwann beiße wie viele Anfragen kriegt ihr denn jetzt weniger geworden oder.
Es ist sehr viel weniger geworden das war eine Zeitlang mal so alle paar Monate jetzt ist es vielleicht einmal im Jahr oder so was soll das ist wirklich nicht viel.
Gute wird gute pädagogische Arbeit gleich.
Route für Fortbildungsmaßnahmen durch unsere Antworten vielleicht auch erreicht.
Mir geht's nur darum dass Dirk wo steht Tor Servers nicht hier haben immer cooperi.
Naja also ich meine man kann hier halt eben feststellen dass das vielleicht irgendwie überbordende Maßnahmen waren dass sie uns auch hätten Fragen können und so weiter
aber so lief halt eben nicht es liefert nur mal so
die standen in der Wohnung die haben alle Schubladen aufgemacht haben jedes jeden Gegenstand rausgenommen und wieder zurück gelegt haben alles mitgenommen an externen Festplatten USB Sticks SD Karten SIM-Karten,
haben sich sehr interessiert für die Sticker die so bei mir rumfliegen wir haben so eine nette Kaffeedose
da ist ein Aufkleber drauf Barista Barista antifascista die.
Auch noch das wurde natürlich auch alles abfotografiert
zur Bundesagentur gegen Arbeit dicker das war natürlich Albaner alles Indizien dafür dass sie am richtigen Ort sind,
ich habe so schöne Sticker von der königlich bayerischen Antifa.
Das sind alles natürlich klare Indizien dass sie dass sie da durchaus was gefunden haben
und dann haben sie sich halt irgendwann gut dann haben die das alles eingesackt sind auch die Unterlagen irgendwie so,
durchgegangen um festzustellen ob ich wirklich nichts habe zu dem Verein das war eigentlich alles auch soweit dann durch aber sie haben sich eben gewundert warum sie bei mir weder einen lap,
noch einen Desktop-PC finden konnten und habe mich deswegen so ein bisschen so nach meinen Arbeitsräumen befragt und dann,
sozusagen ja habe ich habe ich denen erzählt es gibt dieses openlab Augsburg als Hackerspace,
und das könnte man durchaus als Arbeitsräume sehen in denen ich was mache
und dann habe ich denen angeboten weil ich,
besondere auch wusste ich habe da so eine kleine Kiste im Regal da liegen vielleicht auch noch irgendwelche uralt Festplatten drin aber da ist jetzt auch nichts anderes drin was mir jetzt irgendwie fehlen würde wenn Sie das auch noch mitnehmen,
und habe Ihnen neben Angeboten zum Abschluss dieser Geschichte die dürfen gerne jetzt hier zusammenpacken alles fertig machen ihre Taschen mitnehmen und dann gehen wir mal zu den makerspace und hole meine Kiste raus.
Und so kamen eben dieses openlab auch noch sozusagen in den Fokus der Ermittlungen.
Bleiben wir mal noch ganz kurz bevor wir zum openlab weitermachen.
Jens kubieziel und seine Frau wurden zum gleichen Zeitpunkt zu Hause aufgesucht hier,
gibt's bei Netflix Orkun sehr schönes Interview mit den beiden,
gestaltet sich diese Sache natürlich schon ein bisschen anders also das klettersachen kurz zu 1 ohne dass Polizisten bei so einer Hausdurchsuchung auch mal freundlich sind ne das ist jetzt der hat jetzt nichts damit zu tun
die Maßnahme rechtens ist oder nicht die wollen die wahrscheinlich auch haben auch eine Vorstellung darüber wie entspannt sie ihren Tag verbringen und die können natürlich Sie das für sich angenehmer machen
wenn sie wenn sie das hinkriegen ohne dass sie nachher.
Die verwickeln sich in Gespräche es geht darum dass du dich in durch eine freundliche Atmosphäre in Gespräche verwickeln.
Wo du dich am besten noch selber belasse.
Wo du denen viel Informationen gibst das war mir alles klar und das war mir alles bewusst auch durch die Vorbildung durch
Vorträge und so weiter dass das jetzt gerade eigentlich ne aushorchen ist und kein freundliches geklaute aber ich habe dennoch mitgespielt und Anführungszeichen weil eben ich uns nichts vorzuwerfen habe,
und ich dann natürlich schon Interesse hatte,
jetzt nicht komplett irgendwie zu sagen ich sage jetzt nicht das wäre vielleicht in anderen Situation anders gelaufen aber so auf Basis dessen also I was es sozusagen jeden Anraten kann und das erste was man eigentlich bei diesem Verhalten bei Hausdurchsuchung auch hört ist,
Ruhe bewahren es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund irgendwie in Stress zu verfallen es gibt sowieso keinen keine großen Möglichkeiten man hat wenn die Beziehung
da sind ich habe auch nicht irgendwie sofort gesagt ich will jetzt sofort einen Anwalt anrufen weil das auch was was in dem diesen Hinweisen eben immer wieder kommt,
das kann man dann im Nachgang gemütlich machen und eben diese schweige Optionen die man hat nichts zu sagen habe ich nicht wahrgenommen sondern ich hatte ein Interesse da also zu diskutieren und zu mich zu unterhalten
und das wurde später auch zitiert also später als ich dann zur formellen Zeugenaussage da war.
Wurden Sachen die sozusagen in diesem Geplänkel mit diesen 6 Beamten so passiert sind wo ich aber sehr bewusst war was ich da sage auch wieder zitiert also das ist genau diese Masche,
dass sie einem gar sozusagen gegenüber freundlich tun und so weiter und und das dient der des Informationsgewinn ist klar.
Ich denke man sollte schon jetzt für,
wir kommen noch nachher zur im zweiten Fall ein Hausdurchsuchung wenn man da jetzt nicht an dem Punkt ist dass man sich mit diesem Thema schon sehr ausführlich auseinandergesetzt hat und z.b. auch über eine Wohnung verfügt wo nichts drin ist,
was die wenigsten tun dann ist das natürlich sehr richtig freundlich zu bleiben und gibt kein kein also wer da jetzt irgendwie Stress macht wird dadurch
Gitterrost keinen Gewinn ziehen aber sich mit denen zu unterhalten ist in der Regel,
grundsätzlich erstmal nicht die richtige Detern wie Boris gerade schon sagt was er denn was er gesagt hat war nachher.
Stand halt irgendwo und wenn man gerade die weiße Leute werden in so einer Situation nicht die Ruhe bewahren werden nicht
darüber nachdenken was sie sagen und dann ist das glaube ich keine gute Idee mit den mit denen zu sprechen bin noch ganz kurz hier auf die Durchsuchung beim bei der Familie kubieziel,
Eigendesign vojensky in diesem Interview aussagt so ein einfacher Anruf oder Besuch hätte natürlich diese Lage aufklären können und wir reden die bis jetzt hat mir davon gesprochen sie waren bei dir in
Augsburg sie waren aber zeitgleich eben in in Jena bei kubieziel sie waren in Berlin an gleich zwei Orten.
Und sie waren in Dresden an dem wo ihr den eigentlichen Vereinssitz angemeldet habt in einer Anwaltskanzlei.
Da waren auch.
Den ein und dass man Anwaltskanzleien nicht so einfach durchsuchen kann.
Ja da gibt es so gewisse Hürden das war auch Gespräch schon damals bei der Vereinsgründung mit dem Anwalt eben den wir da nutzen und er war damals schon das Szenario dass das dann keinen Schutz mehr bietet
also indem
im Moment wo sie so Durchsuchungsbeschlüsse sich ausdenken und der Vereinssitz eine Kanzlei ist kommt die Kanzlei nicht nicht
drumrum also die müssen da sicherlich noch mal zwei Minuten länger drüber nachdenken bevor sie die Unterschrift drunter setzen aber das war's eigentlich also das war das was man so weiß ich glaube das bezieht sich auch oft auf irgendwie Hollywood und USA und so weiter da mag es vielleicht noch andere würden geben aber in Deutschland ist es alles eigentlich eher,
Weiber was was eben die Aussagen dieses Anwalts war nicht gegeben dass du da einen besonderen Schutz hast also ja
sie waren bei allen unseren Vorständen wir sind drei Vorstände das ist der Jurist Jens und ich Juristin Berlin Jens in Jena bei mir in Augsburg sie waren am Vereinssitz in Dresden
und was dann noch Nachhinein rauskam ist dass Sie beim Julian waren der vor Jahren mal bei uns Vorstand war der leider bei uns noch eine Bankvollmacht hatte die wir immer mal wegmachen wollten aber irgendwie verplant haben.
Mit anderen Worten sie sind auch über die IBAN zu euch gekommen weil bei er wird mich auch aufgefallen dass im rise up impressum steht nämlich die IBAN aber da steht nicht Zügel Freunde.
Also die haben sich wohl auch von der GLS die Kontoauszüge geholt die mit in dem Beschluss stehen,
das heißt man kann davon ausgehen dass das da wahrscheinlich auch einen Beschluss gab der in Richtung GLS gewandert ist für die Kontoauszüge.
Was soll die Kontoauszüge zurückreichen die sich geholt haben.
Also laut Beschluss.
Bezieht sich die Beschlagnahmung von Gegenständen die immer auf ab dem Zeitraum 1.1.2018 ich
kann mir vorstellen dass die GLS sich sozusagen dass sie dort nicht durchsucht haben und sondern dass sie da einfach das angefordert haben und dann liegt es wahrscheinlich auf der Basis ab,
also erster erster 218 wahrscheinlich weil's dann Zusammenhang gibt den zeitlichen mit diesem Krawall Blog kann ich mir vorstellen wann der dann irgendwann aufgetaucht ist
und dann sind sie nicht weiter zurückgegangen aber bei uns war das so dass sie sich sozusagen trotz expliziter Aussagen von Joris der ja dann die Dokumente hatte der die auch nicht bei ihm zu Hause waren übrigens da können wir auch noch drauf drüber sprechen alles mitgenommen haben also alle Konten eigentlich
er ist der Beschluss nur für dieses eine Konto sehen wir alle konnten alle Kontoauszüge mitgenommen alle Belege und so weiter seit Vereinsgründung 211
also sie haben alle unsere Unterlagen.
Also Kontoauszüge von euch nicht von der Bank.
Das was Sie bei uns geholt haben waren Kontoauszüge von allen Konten wir haben Projekt konnten pro Projekt dadurch sonst Beschluss bezieht sich eigentlich nur auf dieses eine projektkontor das weißer projektkonto aber sie haben alles mitgenommen habe.
Ist aber auch schon meine gute Informationen zu wissen dass Bank noch in der Lage sind einmalig alte Kontoauszüge schnell zuschicken zu können auch wenn sie immer behaupten die würden nur drei Monate.
Ich weiß nicht ob das dann irgendwie kostenfrei ist dieser dieser Service oder ob das genauso viel kostet wie wenn man die selber nach fordert.
Ja das zu teuer werden.
Also alle hier drin ganz klares überschreiten dessen des pistes Soju durchsuchungs Auftrages oder nicht.
Ja also ich meine ich spiele jetzt mal die Rolle von dem Menschen der das ganze verteilt.
Bleib mal ruhig in deiner Rolle.
Ja also ich meine ich sage jetzt mal wenn ich jetzt da im mittlere und ich mache eigentlich organisierte Kriminalität und ich
habe von bayerischen Verfassungsschutz die Aussage der comment wie 2003 heute,
adida Krawall machen und dann schaue ich mir sowas an und sage ok dieser Verein muss dann drin verwickelt sein der betreibt vielleicht sogar diese Server
dann haben die gar keine andere Wahl als die müssen ja davon ausgehen dass wenn wir jetzt da irgendwie in dieses Milieu reingesteckt werden Haustieren aus deren schwarz-weiß.
Sehr gut aber muss doch klar sagen an der Stelle war er die Gedankenkette interessiert schon zerbrochen.
Ja ja also ich war.
Arbeit hätte man nie kommen dürfen.
Explizit es ist völlig absurd wie das Jahr abgelaufen ist
ich möchte jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit nur sagen ja ich kann es nachvollziehen blablabla sondern nein es ist völlig absurd es kann nicht angehen dass das nicht vorher festgestellt wurde dass das vielleicht
bisschen abartig ist was sie geplant wird und dann ja auch exerziert wird als ich meine da steckt der Planung und Logistik dahinter
Überfall an diesen Orten waren Augsburger Beamten dabei also das muss man sich auch mal vorstellen die müssen wir hinfahren
die müssen irgendwie übernachten bei uns war bei mir jetzt in Augsburg war ein technischer Sachverständiger vom LKA Bayern dabei aus Bamberg der ist noch einen Tag vorher angefahren und so weiter ich meine das ist ja absolut.
Ist nicht so dass da mal eben eine Streife losgefahren ist und mal irgendwie Geko.
Nee mal geklopft hat oder so sondern das ist es war ne.
Eine richtig große Aktion.
Und das ist klar dass dass das ist dass das nicht geht dass das darf nicht geben und da gibt's jetzt eben verschiedene Rechtswege die wir da ergriffen haben seitdem,
und ich ich bin da auch sozusagen guter Dinge dass das im Nachhinein für rechtswidrig erklärt wird diese ganze Aktion.
Jetzt ist er das openlab auch noch mal dann genauer angeschaut worden obwohl du da alles nur eine Kiste holen wolltest mich das richtig verstanden habe.
Also ich würde das gerne mal vergleichen mit der Situation mayores in Berlin wo eben auch die Unterlagen nicht waren sondern wir haben den im feuerfesten Schrank in dem Büro er hat ihnen angeboten er führte zu diesem feuerfesten Schrank insbesondere weil sie bei ihm zu Hause
Hinweise auf dieses Büro gefunden haben
da war noch Quittungen für die Adresse von dem Büro und sowas war also absehbar die gehen da sowieso hin egal was jetzt abläuft aber er hat eben dann gesagt okay dann begleite ich euch halt hin dort haben sie nicht durchsucht
das sind Büroräume die sind relativ neutral und da steht ein schöner großer Stahlschrank mit so einem riesen schönen Schlüssel mit dem man den Stahlschrank öffnen kann,
dann hat er ihnen sozusagen eigentlich verweigert dass sie alles mitnehmen sondern nur das was über dem Schluss gedeckt wäre und in Augsburg gestaltet es sich am Anfang,
nee nicht erfolgreich hast du dir immer alles mitgenommen das war sozusagen auch.
Sie haben Dinge mitgenommen die sie eigentlich gar nicht hätten mitnehmen dürfen.
Meines Verständnis nach ist das so sie könnten sich vielleicht rausreden weil hier halt drin steht sonstige Unterlagen schriftlicher oder elektronischer Art die irgendwie in Zusammenhang mit dem Krawall Block oder rise abstehen
darüber können Sie natürlich glaube ich so ein catch-all machen also da müssen wir mal sehen aber meiner Meinung nach ist es überhaupt nicht gedeckt vor allem weil eben da steht der Zeitpunkt ab dem 1.12.
Also wir hätten gerne ab. E-xtb. Doc & Standpunkt Stern.
Also jedenfalls in Augsburg liest das so ich habe die zu meiner Kiste geführt in dem space,
ich war eigentlich im rausgehen mit der Kiste damit Sie sie im Tageslicht beäugen können und da vielleicht auch noch ein paar Gegenstände sich mitnehmen können und dann im rausgehen das war eigentlich alles schon alle waren mental drauf eingestellt dass das jetzt hier dann vorbei ist,
haben sie auf einem Whiteboard so chemische Formeln gesehen wir haben so ein großes Whiteboard im Hauptraum hängen,
wo in verschiedene Kritzeleien drauf waren irgendwelche binärbäume,
Schaltpläne das ist natürlich auch dann interessant und eben eine chemische Formel und daraufhin war es so ein bisschen so heißt es also eskaliert kann man jetzt schon,
durchaus als Wort benutzen da war noch zwei andere Leute in dem Space die haben da gerade mal übernachtet und die mussten wir dann schleunigst wecken und dann wurden wir auf die Terrasse gebeten wir durften die räumlich
nicht mehr betreten die haben uns weiter aus sozusagen freundlich draußen unterm unterhalten haben wir uns mit denen,
also alles sozusagen nach und nach wie vor in den Modus die wollen jetzt von uns natürlich alles mögliche erfahren aber es entstand der Vorwurf der Vorbereitung eines Sprengstoffattentat,
und dann haben die da Verstärkung gerufen haben diskutiert drinnen.
Also weil sie da eine chemische Formel auf dem Waldbad gesehen haben ausschließlich deshalb.
Ja unten wir haben ja so ein großes Lagerregal das sind ganz viele Kisten die meisten davon sogar einigermaßen ordentlich beschriftet und da steht halt auch eine Kiste da steht Genitalien drauf,
und das war natürlich dann sozusagen der Zusammenhang klar hier gibt's Chemikalien und da steht eine chemische Formel an der Wand dass das.
Dann nur eine Bombe sein was.
Wir haben auch noch so eine Gegendemo Flyer gehabt für so eine AFD Gegendemo den haben sie sich auch gleich beschlagnahmt.
Ja das sind dass ich alles indizieren für für die dass das dass sie da was holen können.
Was war das für Chemikalien.
Also was soll ich ihm egal in da war ich weiß das nicht genau was ich halt über die Jahre unserem Hackerspace so ansammelt es kann schon die ein oder andere Säure da dabei sein aber halt so Haushalt überall haushaltsüblichen Zeug würde ich sagen.
Also für Platinen ätzen und so.
Genau
Platinen ätzen 3D Drucker reinigen diese Isopropanol Geschichte haben wir das weiß ich ich bin da jetzt auch nicht so firm wir haben keinen Chemielabor so ist es nicht wert
kleine Holzwerkstatt werden der größere Elektronik Ecke und ansonsten sind das meiste sind halt auf der Leute die halt so im Raum rumhängen mit ihren Laptops und in der Lounge,
also so der ganz klassische Chaos makerspace würde ich mal sagen,
mit so ein bisschen Flaschen werden paar Leute die haben also Analogfotografie Sachen gemacht also da war natürlich auch Tim Italien dabei für für Analogfotografie und sowas.
Für dich die verdächtigt haben so und dann haben sie das openlab auch noch komplett geputzt.
Na ja dann hat es doch schon noch mal zwei Stunden gedauert sie haben erstmal die die sie täten festgestellt von den zwei Leuten die da leider völlig unbeteiligt gerade an dem Tag dort waren,
das war dann so ab 9 Uhr waren wir dort also dir waren also um 6 Uhr bei mir
um 9 Uhr ungefähr wann sie bei mir fertige da waren wir bei makerspace und dann haben sie zwei Stunden saßen wir auf dieser Terrasse fest sie haben uns auch nicht gehen lassen es war aber auch noch nicht klar was jetzt eigentlich von Vorwurf oder erhoben werden kann
und haben alle mögliche Elektronik auch von diesen beiden beschlagnahmt,
dann hieß es wir sind jetzt alle vorläufig festgenommen und wir werden jetzt mal mitgenommen,
dann haben sie uns einzelnen Autos gesetzt und zum Polizeipräsidium gefahren dass es 500 Meter weit also es war keine lange Fahrt und uns daneben in Zellen gestoppt.
Aber jeder hat sein eigenen Transportwagen.
Piraten eigentransport Wagen und natürlich auch jeder hat seine eigene Zelle bekommen
in dem Zuge haben sie sich dann auch noch leider sozusagen im letzten Moment für mein Schlüsselbund interessiert der war bis dahin keine Rolle gespielt und haben da noch meinen Smartcard wieder mit Smartcard mir abgenommen.
Deswegen können wir kein PGP schreiben.
Genau genau bei der yubikey am selben Schlüsselbund den haben sie nicht als irgendein interessantes Objekt erkennen können.
Das ist auch sehr nett weil mit dem kann ich schon noch einige gute Dinge tun.
So in diesem Moment sieht man die Geschichte nimmt eine etwas dramatische Wendungen du bist jetzt verhaftet da sind
bitte welche unbeteiligten die einfach nur in diesem Hackerspace waren du hast jetzt du sagst du diverse Elektronik wo wir dann irgendwie wissen was er was damit gemeint ist aber damit deshalb Zeit Laptops Telefone ne.
Laptops Telefone der eine hat relativ viele so Mikrocomputer Dinge gehabt irgendwelche Arduino Boards Raspberry Pi es sowas in die Richtung ja speichern.
Bombenbau Computer alt aber so haben die die inzwischen wieder.
Die beiden haben ihre Sachen wieder bekommen ja.
Nee wir nicht also alle die jetzt in dem Zusammenhang mit den direkteren Zusammenhang also der ist ja auch schon nicht mehr da
aber alle mal was sozusagen mit den Zwiebel Freunden in Verbindung stehen die da
haben wir die Aussage dass sie immer noch ausgewertet werden was ich sehr interessant finde weil z.b. bei Heise,
die haben die Staatsanwaltschaft zuletzt dazu bewegt auszusagen.
Dass sie wissen dass wir nur ein Spendenkonto für Reiter verwalten und das erklärt sich mir überhaupt nicht wie man heute noch sozusagen,
wir haben am Montag die Aussage Gießen Montag die Aussage bekommen dass wir unsere Sachen nicht zurückgehalten weil die noch ausgewertet werden.
Zeitgleich sozusagen am Mittwoch hat heiße angefragt und da war der Staatsanwaltschaft schon klar dass wir nur ein Spendenkonto verwalten und seitdem.
Zu sehr interessant was die da jetzt alles haben ne.
Ja klar also da.
Das wenn man das doch mal hattest gibt man doch schnell so schnell nicht aus der Hand und sind gerade in Augsburg ist doch da passiert doch mal was so da gibt's ja nicht mal was zu tun fällt endlich mal,
fährt endlich mal ein bisschen Arbeit an du findest trotzdem nur so wissen daher gesagt da wird ein bisschen Elektronik weggenommen.
Bei kubieziel ist davon natürlich dann auch direkt die Existenz bedroht weil da natürlich und natürlich wenn die einmal im Haus sind dann Computer ist da werden halt alle wird mitgenommen das betraf halt dann auch den
am Computer
von Heidi Cudi kubieziel deren Computer jetzt auch einfach weg ist und du weißt auch nicht wann du den wieder bekommst ne wenn das also Ding wenn das einmal in Händen der Polizei war ist halt stellt sich halt auch die Frage willst du denn überhaupt wieder haben und es stellt sich die Frage.
Kaufst du dir einen neuen was machst du jetzt da sind ja auch keine billigen Geräte muss halt in bis nach irgendwelchen müssen neue Computer beschafft werden und zwar subito.
Ja du das war nicht nur bei Jens so sondern das war bei allen von uns so dass wir ja auch Jobs haben,
und ich den auch gesagt habe explizit dass das Geräte sind die noch nicht mal mir gehören sondern die der Firma gehören für dich arbeite und dass ich ohne das eigentlich nicht arbeiten kann wir haben EU-Projekte das sind 5000000 Euro Projekte,
wo ich jetzt eigentlich seit zwei Wochen gerade nicht sinnvoll arbeiten kann also
ja ich kann jetzt die Website von dem EU-Projekt nicht aktualisieren weil die meine Smartcard haben et cetera et cetera also das auch der Jurist der ist selbstständig der braucht seine Geräte zum Arbeiten natürlich sind alle drei von uns,
von von den Vorständen im Endeffekt durften wir am nächsten Tag in Media Markt laufen.
Und selbst dann hast du ja noch nicht irgendwie eine Grundlage mit der du weiterarbeiten kannst wir sind jetzt auch mit den Zwiebel Freundin,
wir müssen Umsatzsteuervoranmeldungen machen ja ist halt ein bisschen schwierig wenn die alle unsere Unterlagen haben und ein bisschen schwierig wenn die alle elektronischen Speichermedien haben.
Mit dem Finanzamt erklärt warum du gerade keine Anmeldung machst dann mach das auch einen Scheiß Eindruck wurde ja hallo Finanzamt wir wurden gerettet wir haben nichts mehr.
Ja ja ist halt Sofa ja.
Ah okay alles klar Prüfung zwiebelfreunde 1. Januar.
Ich mein das ist ja jetzt schon so dass wir allen unseren sozusagen Geschäftspartnern mitteilen dürfen und den irgendwie erklären dürfen warum wir jetzt gerade nicht sinnvoll kommunizieren können damit fängt sie an und auch nicht sinnvoll arbeiten können also ich habe mir das musst du mir jetzt erstmal Urlaub nehmen.
Was ist sozusagen in den Zwangsurlaub versetzt worden durch diese Aktion.
Das dann noch bei Verträgen bei beim Ehepartner noch mal genauso oder bei Mitbewohnern gerne mal passiert,
dann kommt vielleicht noch einen Button Projekt dazu wo man nicht einfach mal wo wo war neben keine Option ist ne sowas wie.
Sie sie schaffen die Abgabe nächste Woche nicht.
Ihr Pech.
Jawohl Leute vielleicht auch einfach auf eine Gelegenheit warten einmal rein zu drücken.
Also es war schon spannend es war interessant uns besondere bei dem einen jetzt von denen völlig unbeteiligten dem wurde am,
Donnerstag gesagt er darf seine Sachen abholen und die Durchwahl gegeben von dem zugehörigen Beamten,
das hat uns der Anwalt mitgeteilt dass ihm das gerade mitgeteilt wurde der hat gerade mit dem gesprochen und wir rufen drei Minuten später an ja der ist außer Haus,
nicht mehr zu sprechen,
ja gut kann das jemand anderes autorisieren wir haben gerade sozusagen erfahren wir dürfen Sachen abholen ja nee das kann nur der der ja ob der nächste Woche im Haus ist das wissen sie nicht,
also ich war die spielen da schon natürlich auch ihre Macht aus und also ich fand es kann eigentlich nicht sein dass es nicht irgendwo hinterlegt ist und dass man es dann halt einfach abholen kann,
sondern da hat man schon gemerkt was die Ausprägung und von so einem von so einem,
Modus ist in dem die sich irgendwie bewegen dass sie natürlich jetzt uns durchaus da noch Dinge reinwürgen möchte ich denen jetzt gerne hier auch mal unterstellen dass,
weil ich absolut.
Jedenfalls was wir jetzt getan haben auch hinsichtlich dessen dass der AFD Parteitag vorbei ist gibt es ja eigentlich auch gar keine Ländlichkeit und Dringlichkeit mehr,
sondern wir haben jetzt einen Antrag auf Versiegelung gestellt das zumindest bis zur gerichtlichen Entscheidung alle beschlagnahmen Gegenstände nicht mehr weiter ausgewertet werden dieser Antrag ist gestellt gut wann die den jetzt sozusagen,
überhaupt zu in Empfang nehmen und drüber nachdenken,
das weiß ich nicht genau aber ich denke die haben gar keine andere Wahl als das dass zumindest erstmal alles zu versiegeln und nicht weiter auszuwerten.
Kannst du schon bei der Durchsuchung stellen geht also kannst du sofort machen aber ja m40d diese Versiegelung bedeutet
das Polizisten nicht drin rumfuchteln dürfen sondern nur Staatsanwalt oder Richter was unter Umständen von Vorteil ist vor allem wenn man in einer kleineren Stadt wohnt in der man vielleicht die Polizisten kennt,
den nicht ganz überträgt.
Also der Grund warum wir das nicht vorher machen konnten war eben diese diese angebliche zeitliche Korrelation zudem noch stattzufinden den Parteitag da hätte das da wäre es sofort abgelehnt.
Da wo das gerade wegen Gefahr im Pool.
Reha Almke wegen wegen anstehender.
Wann fährt Zug Vollzug.
Ich verzog gesagt Gefahr im Vollzug.
Diverse Foto noch nicht vollzogen.
Das stimmt, einfach.
Naja und dann saß ich in dieser Zelle habe meine Rechtsbelehrung als Beschuldigter bekommen
und da gehört natürlich dann unter anderem dazu dass man halt eben nicht aussagen muss darf man Anwalt hinzuziehen und so weiter
die haben sich auch Mühe gegeben gegeben bei mir dann meinen Anwalt ausfindig zu machen weil ich hatte ja keine Geräte und nichts mehr an mir also auf Twitter kursieren jetzt schon so,
Rezepte das man doch am besten der Anwalts Nummer auf dem paar Stück Papier haben sollte das ist sicherlich ganz gut die haben sie war bei mir sogar Mühe gegeben und den irgendwie nach gegoogelt und so weiter und hinterher telefoniert.
Ja
und dann hatte ich Anwalts Kontakt ich meine im Endeffekt was der mir gesagt hat war eben das was man eben auch klassischerweise hört bei diesem Fall wie verhält dafür halte ich mich nämlich einfach nicht sagen er hat mir angeboten sofort zu kommen aber wenn es mir gut geht soweit,
dann können wir das auch verschieben bis zu dem Zeitpunkt wo sie mich vernehmen wollen und natürlich nicht die an der Vernehmung teilnehmen bis er eingetroffen ist,
dazu kam es aber gar nicht mehr.
Essen wichtiger als pektinwerk habe ich die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen außen vor gelassen haben bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt gründete sich diese Durchsuchung
darauf dass ihr als Zeugen.
Da sein sollte nicht als Beschuldigter also den war schon klar dass ihr nicht diese Webseite betreibt den war auch irgendwie klar dass ihr im Zweifelsfall nicht über eure damit irgendetwas zu tun habt.
Und dass euch nicht zur Last gelegt werden kann das irgendwo beim italienischen Haus da jemand eine Web-Site hat sondern sie haben die Durchsuchung bei zeugen.
Als ich eben auch sehr
also das finde ich auch schon ein sehr komisches Konstrukt ne also das die natürlich alles dürfen wenn Ihnen wenn Sie das an einem Richter vorbeikommt bekommen ist natürlich klar aber bei zeugen kann man natürlich auch einfach mal
sich melden ne da kann einfach anrufen und sagen Sie mal wie sieht das aus hier.
Das ist eben auch was was jetzt aus so wie verhalte ich mich bei Hausdurchsuchungen eigentlich selten vorkommt weil es eben auch so selten vorkommt dass Zeugen durchsucht wurden jetzt just hatten wir ja wieder die Geschichte in Dortmund sozusagen mit dem wissenschaftsladen
da ist es genauso das ist Paragraph 103 den kann man sich mal vergegenwärtigen und durchlesen wie das mit so zeugen Durchsuchungen ist also da gibt es eine Rechtsgrundlage für.
Paragraph 103 von welchem Gesetz.
SR StPO.
Praxisordnung.
Zustimmungserfordernis bei Zurücknahme.
103-105.
Das StVO ist der StPO seine StPO 103-105 rb303.
StPO 103 Durchsuchungen durchsuchen bei anderen Personen bei anderen Personen sind Durchsuchungen nur zur Ergreifung des Beschuldigten oder zur Verfolgung von Spuren einer Straftat
oder zu Beschlagnahme bestimmter Gegenstände und nur dann zulässig wenn Tatsachen vorliegen aus
denen zu schließen ist das die gesuchte Person Spur oder Sache sich in den zu durchsuchen den Räumen befindet
entscheidend ist hier natürlich bestimmte Gegenstände weil da Moritz egal schon gesagt hat dagegen wurde ja verstoßen indem Sie einen möglichen Scheiß eingesammelt haben bestimmt heißt das sind die Gegenstände den Besuches Beschluss oder in der in der Anordnung auch spezifisch benannt sind
zum Zwecke der Ergreifung eines Beschuldigten der dringend verdächtig ist eine Straftat nach Papa Papp des StGB oder in Verbindung mit des StGB.
Oder einen der in dieser Vorschrift blablabla ganz haben ist eine Durchsuchung von Wohnungen und anderen Räumen auch zulässig wenn diese sich in einem Gebäude befinden von dem aufgrund von Tatsachen anzunehmen ist dass sich der Beschuldigte
in ihm auffällt die Beschränkung des Satzes 1 des Absatzes 1 Satz 1 gelten nicht für Räume in denen der Beschuldigte ergriffen worden ist
oder dir während der Verfolgung betreten hat also der der Teil der hier bei euch ganz klar gezogen haben muss ist der bestimmte Gegenstände,
spezifische durchsuchte Räume und hier ganz klar openlab dafür war das nicht gegeben.
Aber dafür alles was bei euch gesucht wurde waren es bestimmte Gegenstände also am Ende natürlich hier ganz klare Überschreitung der der Kompetenzen.
Ja und sag auch keine Tatsachen vor also das würde ich jetzt auch mal stark bezweifeln dass hier irgendwelche Tatsachen also mir ist jetzt juristische Definition von Tatsache natürlich mal wieder nicht klar aber.
Ich würde.
Aber eine ähnliche E-Mail-Adresse und ich sammle Spenden für irgendetwas.
Na gut also ist ja am Ende alles auch sehr liquide so eine Definition.
Aber Beschuldigte waren ja hat ja niemanden und wie unterm Sofa versteckt uns wurde ja in dem Sinne auch noch niemand konkret gesucht na also.
Zugeben.
Als was ich meine ist es wurde ja nie ist wurde ja niemand konkret beschuldigt.
Naja unbekannt unbekannte wurden.
Unbekannte na gut aber das ist meine über unbekannte wären sehr keine.
War noch zwei Unbekannte indem.
Suche unbekannte Personen wie sie sind mir unbekannt trifft die Beschreibung ja komplett zu.
Also spezifische Gegenstände waren gefahren genannt indem in dem Befehl das wurde nicht berücksichtigt auf Computer wurden weggenommen wann die unter diesen spezifischen Gegenständen das ist dann eher so Jana jedes Kommunikationsgeräte.
Na ja eben das ist ja eben da der der Knackpunkt an alles was spezifisch gelistet ist und wenn da spezifisch gelistet wird dass es Speichermedien betrifft und sonstige Unterlagen auf denen irgendwelche Daten sein könnten,
können die das ja zum Zeitpunkt der Beschlagnahme nicht unbedingt wissen also bei der Kanzlei haben sie das sehr viel enger ausgelegt bei der Kanzlei haben sie sich die elektronische Kommunikation
die unseres Vereins betreffnis das ist übrigens nicht erfaßt hier das geht nicht um Kommunikation zwischen unserer Kanzlei und uns sondern eigentlich und Kommunikation eben mit diesem krawalltouristen Block oder mit mit rise up,
in Zusammenhang,
und bei der Kanzlei haben sie sich kopieren gezogen also die haben irgendwie an deren E-Mail Systemen rumfuhrwerken für mehrere Stunden bis sie es geschafft hatten die E-Mail-Kommunikation zu extrahieren die mit uns in Zusammenhang steht,
und bei uns sozusagen als Vorstände haben sie das halt einfach betrachtet als ja gut das müssen wir uns halt eben erst im Nachhinein anschauen was davon ist eigentlich wirklich relevante Kommunikation und was sind irgendwie,
z.b. externe Platten meiner Frau mit Familien Bildern drauf und Urlaubsbildern und so weiter.
Das ist halt also die nicht mir ist
klar dass du da jetzt auch oft genug drüber geredet hast und dich damit ihr oft genug auseinandergesetzt hast das ist für dich jetzt nicht mehr so schockierend ist aber das sind halt echt mal fürchterliche Eingriffe ne als sie die Computer weg
überleg mal.
Na ja und die Daten die da drauf sind also erst bei Familienangehörigen sind die halt nicht unbedingt so verschlüsselt dass ich davon ausgehe dass sie da nicht rankommen sondern das sind einfach,
gartenshops rufst du an und dann findest du da sicherlich irgendwie das ein oder andere interessante Foto,
ich muss mich schon fragen ob Sie dass mir jetzt in 5 Jahren noch mal hinlegen oder so was die da alles so an Fotos was weiß ich irgendwelche Nacktfotos irgendwelche anderen was auch immer sie da jetzt finden könnten keine Ahnung,
man was man halt über die Jahre so angehäuft an an persönlichen Daten.
Und alle Leute die jemals zu euch gespendet haben sind jetzt dort auch erstmal mit ihm im beifanger und da ist nun wirklich sorry weil also der besteht einfach keinen Zusammenhang für diesen Blog dass da irgend jemand betrieben hat.
Also insbesondere bei denen konnten die nicht mit Weiß auf in Zusammenhang stehen kann ich das absolut,
nicht nachvollziehen warum soll es mitgenommen haben also auch die torservice Geschichte,
auch andere Projekte und da ich meine die Kontoauszüge könnten Sie sich bei der GMS holen was sie da nicht gekriegt haben ist wie er die wenn wir wenn wir Projekte unterstützen finanziell also die ausgehenden Zahlungen sind dass ich dir die auch da interessant.
Bei den einen gehen dann haben sie sich dafür interessiert auch bei der Befragung ob wir den Spenden von den krawalltouristen bekommen haben was er irgendwie so eine absurde Frage ist.
Touristeninfo.
Genau krawalltourist,
Spenden oder hallo von den krawalltouristen im Spenden bitte Betreff oder was weiß ich was sie sich da vorgestellt haben aber bei den ausgehenden Zahlungen ist uns insbesondere unsere Funktion bei Projekten
die Identitäten dieser Aktivisten zu schützen das heißt,
dir haben z.b. eine Partnerschaft eine genau exakt zu identische Partnerschaft mit Tales mit dem TS Projekt Sonne thorleif distribution.
BMI siak die amnestic wird wie heißt das Wort an das amnestische sowieso Leitsystem.
Gar nicht zusammen ja also im Endeffekt Live-System dass du blutest und du ziehst insta
dann weiter deinen Speicher es geht alles über TOR was du da drin machst alle Anwendungen wieder mitgeliefert werden sind vorkonfiguriert
dafür sichere Kommunikation und das sind alles Leute die unter Pseudonymen arbeiten und das auch mit mit sehr großem Verständnis eigentlich alle,
also das ist dass ich meiner Katze aus verschiedenen Richtungen Gefährdungen und unsere Funktion dort ist diese Identitäten zu schützen das heißt,
wie in der Praxis läuft es so dass die von uns Bargeld bekommen das geht steuerrechtlich nur dann wenn wir uns
eine Quittung geben lassen und auf dieser Quittung muss der real name stehen und nicht nur das sondern unsere Steuerkanzlei hat uns irgendwann mal dazu genötigt bei uns die Ausweise vorlegen zu lassen
Justus was ich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen und die ausweisnummern auf diese Quittung anzuschreiben
deswegen das ist sozusagen das sensibelste Material dass wir haben ist die dezidiert der Schutz diese Aktivisten des haben wir nie irgendwo digital gespeichert gehabt davon gibt's keine Kopien das ist alles in diesem feuerfesten Schrank
gewesen und jetzt war der Polizei.
Das ist nicht gut.
Kein bisschen.
Und das ist schon schwierig davon auszugehen ist dass das ein berechtigter zufälliger Beifang Nissen.
Also ich meine ich ich kann mir das gut vorstellen wie das dann so läuft dann macht er deiner Staatsschutz in Augsburg irgendwie solche Aktionen und dann
gibt's irgendein Bing beim Verfassungsschutz der ja sowieso da schon irgendwie aktiv war in Bayern der dann mal vorbeikommen und sagt ach ihr habt ja hier ganz schöne Unterlagen gibt uns doch da mal irgendwie eine Kopie von,
so kann ich mir das im operativen ganz gut vorstellen ohne Herz der Verfassungsschutz Experte zu sein aber ich denke mir wenn jetzt die Vorwürfe die herum Raum standen gegen Unbekannt Mittwoch zu Straftaten aufrufen und daneben auch Vorbereitung eines,
Sprengstoffattentat also der Paragraph ist auch recht schön,
das ist A310 Strafgesetzbuch war dann zwischendrin sozusagen Ermittlungs Grundlage Vorbereitung eines explosions oder strahlen Verbrechens.
Das da dann sich vielleicht auch so Behörden wie der Verfassungsschutz doch dafür interessieren was da abläuft ich möchte jetzt nicht,
ich meine das kann auch sein dass es von vornherein der Plan war oder dass das von vornherein sozusagen die gesagt haben ja geil zieht es mal durch,
weil wir interessieren uns sowieso schon länger für diese komischen Zügel Freunde da.
Roman so jetzt kommen wir aber endlich noch zu der zu der die haben ja auch eine Bombe bei euch gefunden so ist er also so ist das ja nicht.
Ja also es wurde.
Nicht irgendeine Bombe eine Atombau.
Eine Atombombe gefunden.
Also das Modell einer Atombombe ich weiß nicht in welchem Maßstab ich weiß nicht wie die in Originalgröße wie groß die ist,
die ist mal bei uns so Zeitraum 214 oder sowas entstanden da gibt's auch ein ganz nettes Video auf YouTube wer was wir mit diesem Bomben gemacht haben.
Also die Bombe ist dies anderes als kleines Plastikmodell von einem 3D Drucker gedruckt von der Fat Boy Hiroshima Nagasaki Atombombe der Amerikaner.
Erzähl mir jetzt nicht so sicher ob das überhaupt eine Atombombe ist also das Ding sieht ein bisschen anders aus auf den ersten Blick.
Da sind der Fantasie keine Grenzen gesetzt was das.
Ja sonst halt so ein kleines Bömbchen das ist deswegen jetzt auch so ein bisschen zu so einem kleinen nehmen geworden weil wir nämlich das war halt so unter den beschlagnahmten Gegenständen von einem unserer Mitglieder der noch nicht mal dem zwiebelfreunde noch nicht mal was gesagt hat in der.
Tschuldigung Fatman heiß.
Batman okay ja Fatboy sind die Säcke in die man sich reinsetzen kann.
Na jedenfalls haben wir das Zeug eben was bei ihm beschlagnahmt wurde zurückbekommen und das war alles fein säuberlich in diesem schönen als erwartet Tütchen,
alles war einfach ein so schöner Anblick diese Tütchen mit diesem aber savart Stück von diesen kleinen Bömbchen,
und insbesondere was Micha an dieser diese masarat Stück so besonders begeistert ist das Delikt das dort genau.
Preis.
Weil das Delikt ist Herbeiführen einer Sprengstoffexplosion
also noch nicht mal Vorbereitung oder irgendwas oder Planung oder irgendwas sondern das Delikt
im Rahmen dessen diese Beschlagnahme stattgefunden hat ist scheinbar das Herbeiführen einer Sprengstoffexplosion und das ist schon bisschen harter Tobak dafür dass wir sicherlich keine Explosion herbeigeführt haben.
Zum Fall dass wir zum bisschen plasse plastisch Mode aus dem 3D Drucker was mehr so nachdem Buttplug aussieht als noch irgendwas anderem na da bin ich wiederholen.
Doch nur einmal gesagt werden.
Die.
Es hat natürlich auch System so etwas als der das Ding ist dass ich absolut lächerlich in dieser Tüte drinne aber es hat natürlich durchaus bestimmte,
Vorteile für den weiteren oder willst du bestimmte Folgen für den weiteren Verlauf einer Durchsuchungen oder einer polizeilichen Maßnahme wenn,
der Verdacht eines höheren Deliktes im Raume steht wir erinnern uns an diese ganzen Diskussionen um,
Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachung und Telekommunikationsüberwachung wo in der StPO nämlich geregelt ist okay man darf das bei wenn der Verdacht eines Deliktes folgender Art besteht und.
Die dass das ein als ich jetzt zuletzt im im Bundestag da war als Sachverständiger zu der
letztens zum letzten Staatstrojaner unlocking ist ja auch genau darum dass da eben die die League
Grenze quasi aufgeweitet wurde ne dass man also sagte bei der Einführung von staatstrojanern Wasser nur bei
bei schweren Verbrechen und jetzt verteilt was herbeigeführt und Herbeiführen einer Sprengstoffexplosion ja damit ist halt formale natürlich auch
Tür und hoffe alles andere geöffnet weil viel schlimmere Verbrechen gibt wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr ändern.
Naja und dass sie sich halt damit beschäftigen was jetzt für Aufkleber und was für Flyer an der Tafel hängen und so weiter
kann man dann in dem Zusammenhang auch sehen weil natürlich das alles Indizien sind und die dann sicherlich auch eine Rolle spielen würden wenn es da jetzt zu irgendeinem Verfahren,
kommen würde,
und dann ist natürlich so eine Atombombe in der Tasche vielleicht durchaus auch was was einem dann die Staatsanwaltschaft krumm auslegt.
Können froh sein deswegen nicht wie heißen diese kleinen Gebets Kügelchen die manche Zeitgenossen in der Hand haben die ganze Zeit dass er hätte auch einen schlechten Eindruck gemacht.
Also es war schon.
Za Rosenkranz oder Wien.
Bei den bei den Katholiken bei den katholischen katholischen Fanatikern heißt das Rosenkranz aber die sind ja nicht mehr so gefährlich offenbar.
Nein Bayern sind ja auf jeden Fall nicht hoch für dich.
Wurde auch gerade extra.
Also was ich dann im Nachhinein als ich dann eben aus der Zeugenvernehmung entlassen wurde und die anderen unbeteiligten auch an dem Mittwoch noch,
ich natürlich zurück zum openlab die hatten den Vorstand Schrank aufgebrochen es gibt noch einen zweiten verschlossenen Schrank bei uns das ist unser Süßigkeitenschrank,
zum Nachfüllen vom Automaten den haben sie auch aufgebrochen.
So lange war die bei euch den Donut Schrank aufgebrochen haben.
Die Schweine die Schweine haben von Süßigkeit geklaut.
Und das ist natürlich auch noch sowas wo wir uns jetzt fragen wir haben noch keinerlei Unterlagen zu diesem ganzen Vorkommnissen es war niemand mehr vor Ort von uns nachdem die uns ja alle abgeführt haben das heißt das war ein Abwesenheit diese Durchsuchung,
das Aufbrechen von Vorrat von von von dem Vorstand Schrank da stand auch groß drauf Vorstand,
und man da liegen halt auch wieder natürlich alle möglichen anderen dagegen alle Mission Papiere Mitglieder Mitglieds Anträge,
und so weiter drin und das natürlich ist das im Rahmen von Ermittlungen wo irgendwie die davon ausgehen dass da jetzt irgend Sprengstoffattentat geplant wird muss müssen wir davon ausgehen dass du davon Kopieren haben von dem ganzen Unterlagen,
und das ist natürlich schon eine Ausforschung von der Szene mit wo wir jetzt wirklich vorgehen müssen,
das erstmal klar ist was haben sie überhaupt mitgenommen werden bis heute keine Aussage dazu,
und wie sieht es eigentlich aus mit der Verwertung von dem was du da alles mitgenommen haben aber ich meine da kannst du wahrscheinlich eh nichts dagegen machen wenn es mal beim Verfassungsschutz ist,
dann dann liegt es da.
Wir sind das überhaupt mit Hausdurchsuchung und Zeugen die dabei sein dürfen oder müssen also ist das überhaupt so zulässig das natürlich suchen komplett ohne.
Also in dem Fall,
jetzt bei uns war es so dass sie uns angeboten habt Zeugen hinzuzuziehen die hatten wohl auch schon irgendwie irgendwo sich irgendein zeugen geschnappt aber der ist nicht aufgetaucht weil wir 6 Uhr morgens war wahrscheinlich irgend ein bisschen zu früh für so einen freiwilligen zeugen
aber die haben uns dabei Angeboten an der Tür dass wir uns folgenden zuziehen können zusätzlich bei uns zuhaus.
Eurer Wahl.
Genau genau das ist schon so jetzt bei denen bei der bei der Sprengstoffexplosion Casa mm openlab,
haben die sich natürlich schon entsprechend rückversichern lassen also man hat die wild rum telefonieren sehen und so weiter dass sie das auch alles machen dürfen und dann darfst Du durchaus natürlich in Abwesenheit durchsuchen
haben sie ja aber um beim Julian auch gemacht weil er halt einfach nicht zu Hause war,
aber was ich schon seltsam finde ist dass sie z.b. nicht mal ein Vorstand informiert haben dass das ganze läuft also wir haben Vorstände der Namen stehen auf unserer Internetadresse da standen sogar noch die Handynummern von denen dabei die hätte man alle,
ihr könnt das Open Labs.
Wo du nicht dazu gehörst und dass man dazu zu sein.
Ich bin da Mitglieder einfaches Mitglied her also ich kann nicht zum Vorstand von dem Hackerspace mehr naja gut jedenfalls lief deine Abwesenheit zu Durchsuchungen,
es war auch noch sehr skurril weil sie mich dann bei der Vernehmung die warten irgendwie Telefonkontakt mit den Leuten die da vor Ort sind bei uns im Hackerspace und dann ging es um unsere Überwachung
was denn jetzt hier mit unserer Videoüberwachung ist in unserem Hackerspace wo die Bilder hingehen
weil die dürfen bei solchen polizeilichen Maßnahmen nicht gefilmt werden das war allerdings schon fünf Stunden später also muss sich die Frage stellen sie haben ungefähr fünf Stunden die Räumlichkeiten durchsucht und dann,
kommt sie auf die Idee wir dürfen bei sowas nicht gefilmt werden und das lässt bei mir verboten dass sie das erst gemerkt haben als sie sich überlegt haben wo wollen Sie denn ihre,
Geräte hintun ihre kleinen Dinge die sie hinterlassen wollen bis zum afd-parteitag weil natürlich diese ganzen Vorwürfe
+ AFD Parteitag + dieser Raum und danach war sie einfach alle wieder weg und wir konnten in unsere Räume zurück
ist schon irgendwie seltsam also wir gehen eigentlich davon aus dass sie uns da irgendwelche Hinterlassenschaften mit dagelassen haben irgendwelche Audio oder Video Überwachung und in dem Moment haben Sie gemerkt ja Mist wenn wir die jetzt platzieren wollen und da läuft irgendwie so eine Videokamera mit,
dann wollen wir vielleicht doch wissen wo das hinführt und sie haben sich von mir fünfmal.
Versichern lassen dass das alles dami sind und dass die in Zusammenhang zu sehen sind mit dem aus hygienischen Gründen wird diese Toilette videoüberwacht und dass da nichts aufgenommen wird in unseren Räumen,
na ja das war doch das war noch so ein bisschen nette Anekdote.
Jetzt hört auf das ob nicht aufgenommen wird in euren Räumen müsst ihr euch jetzt noch mal überlegen.
Also jetzt
ist eigentlich davon auszugehen dass das auch so passiert ich habe denen auch am Mittwoch gleich mehrfach angeboten dass ich natürlich die Vorstände gerne gewinnen schicke und befrage lasse,
wie es auch zu dieser Chemikalien Formel am Whiteboard kam und so weiter und in dem Zuge haben sie mir nicht abgeraten das ganze jetzt sozusagen im Verein bekanntzugeben das heißt mit das erste was ich gemacht habe als ich da wieder raus war
war ne mail an unsere Liste zu schicken die Nachbarn haben sie ja auch alle mitbekommen ihrem zwischen drei zeitlich den kompletten Parkplatz abgesperrt,
haben Leute die vorne ins Yoga-Studio wollten aufgehalten und so weiter hier polizeiliche Maßnahmen und so weiter
das heißt es gab schon genug Leute die das eigentlich mitbekommen haben und zwar ich klar dass das sozusagen sowieso sich rumspricht also habe ich mich hingesetzt und das gleich mal alles zusammengefasst,
und bei uns an die Mailingliste geschrieben das ist eine Mailingliste die ist nicht nur für Mitglieder sondern jeder beliebige der sich diese Männer müsste abonniert,
echt hatte am Mittwoch diese Informationen und dann mach's doch fasziniert dass wir jetzt ja zwei Wochen später erst an die Medien gegangen sind damit,
und das in der Zwischenzeit nicht gelegt wurde fand ich sehr nett von von allen Leuten auf dieser auf dieser Mailingliste.
Wahrscheinlich dieser gar keiner mehr.
Ja wir haben schon einen knapp über 100 subscriber und schon recht viele aktive Thread da ja.
Okay also Widerspruch gegen die Maßnahmen.
Genau das erste ist Herausgabe Forderungen der beschlagnahmten Gegenstände insbesondere der Gegenstände die nicht gedeckt sind durch den Durchsuchungsbeschluss also z.b. von Dritten,
von Familienangehörigen von Firmen und so weiter das ganze mit einem falls dies verweigert wird
dann bitten wir um gerichtliche Feststellung was heißt das geht jetzt gerade zum Amtsgericht.
Und jetzt nachdem die AFD Parteitag zu Ende war der Antrag auf sofortige Versiegelung bis zum bis zur Gerichtsentscheidung.
Das war jetzt bisher Soda weg und dann was wir jetzt eben auch noch evaluieren ist entsprechende Schadensersatzforderungen sowohl der Firmen die davon betroffen werden waren als auch als als Vereine.
Und ja grundsätzlich die Rechtswidrigkeit dieses gesamten Dinges im Nachhinein sozusagen zumindest noch,
feststellen zu lang.
Gesetzwidrigkeit auf Basis einer komplett falschen Einschätzung der Situation.
Genau also die Argumentation ist dass es.
Von vornherein klar gewesen sein muss was sicher anstellen und die Unterstellung ist dass du das eben trotzdem durchgezogen haben damit wir uns mal was rein würden können wenn man das jetzt mal so sprechen möchte.
Hausdurchsuchung auf Grundlage einer Fiktion der Nichtbeteiligung.
Mann mann mann ich würde sagen damit haben wir den Status ganz gut wiedergegeben,
der Albtraum für den Chaos Computer Club und seine Freunde ging aber in den folgenden Tagen noch weiter und gestern.
Wurde dann in Dortmund zugeschlagen und dazu holen wir uns jetzt auch noch jemanden in die Sendung.
Und zwar haben wir jetzt in der Leitung live on stage Steffen von Systemausfall Hallo.
Devon du warst obwohl du gar nicht in Dortmund wohnst von der Dortmunder Durchsuchung betroffen erklär's doch erstmal was ist denn eigentlich Systemausfall.
Also die Stimme von allen. Ohrkissen project das Lied Sascha Projekt wo ein paar Leute hinter stecken die,
Dienstleistung anbieten für andere Initiativen Vereine die für ihre Arbeit einfach technische Infrastruktur brauchen sowas E-Mail-Account nehmen müssten Wiki Webseiten.
Verständiger anderen Gruppen zur Verfügung.
Könnte sagen ähnlich wie wie rise up.
Das ist sicherlich mit Walter vergleichbar ja die sind wesentlich kleiner.
Reiterpass kleiner oder oder ihr seid klein.
Wir verlieren kleiner.
Deutsche deutsche Alternativen wären dann noch sowas gibt's noch SO36 net systemli so diese.
Die Schienen italienisch hatten wir gerade auch schon autistici okay also in die in die Richtung geht das.
Leider lässt sich das einordnen.
Gut und was habt ihr euch jetzt da zu Schulden kommen lassen.
Gute Frage die ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht beantworten kann ich kann erzählen was was passiert ist ne.
Wir haben vor Jahren zweiten Tage irgendwo unterbringen wollen am Nachmittag besucht.
Und bei Freunden von uns free.de in Dortmund seine Möglichkeit gefunden und XenServer bei ihnen ins Recknitz einzustellen auf dem Server laufen verschieben oder unter anderen auch Webseiten für.
Andere Projekte.
Und eine diese Webseiten befasste sich scheinbar mit dem Protest gegen geplantes Atommüll-Endlager in in Frankreich.
Und auf dem Blog auf dieser Seite wurden scheinbar Dokumente veröffentlicht die ja da irgendwie nicht hin gehören sollten.
Und ab und dessen gab es bei free.de also genau dort wo der Zählerstand.
Die Lippe auch wohl ziemlich heftig ab also somit Hundertschaft hat man dazwischen drin gelesen und Maschinengewehre und Aufbrechen einer Stahltüre und so weiter
also jetzt nicht einfach nur mankopf freundlich bei irgendeinem Provider an wo die Server stehen und bitte den um die Herausgabe des zugehörigen Servers und die haben auch scheinbar mehr mitgenommen an als nur als einen Server sondern irgendwie so einen
Compact Paket mit verschiedenen Servern drin.
Genau ich will sagen wir haben noch mal gut links und rechts geguckt neben dem eigentlichen was sie im Auge hatten also Hintergrund.
Das projekt Friede ist in Dortmund langer August untergekommen und das ist ein korrekt heraus wo einfach noch viel mehr Initiativen und Vereine drinne sind da haben sie einfach Büroräume.
Edelmut.
Das Gebäude wurde scheinbar Andy abgeriegelt niemand konnte mehr rein und erwärmt irgendwie die selbst Server der Grund der Durchsuchung war.
Wohnen aber glaube ich noch andere Räume betreten die mit dem projekt selber nicht zu tun hatten es wurden andere Sachen scheinbar mitgenommen.
Am also ja noch gut links und rechts geguckt ist wirst du ein bisschen doof.
Eher links als rechts wahrscheinlich oder.
Und vor allem auch gut oben und unten also in dem Haus auch ansässig der Chaostreff Dortmund der dort seine Räumlichkeiten unterhält die wurden
dort ebenfalls teilnehmen im Rahmen dieser Durchsuchung durchsucht.
Amt im Sinne von Polizisten stehen auf einmal drin und sagen hinsetzen.
Nichts mehr anfassen Finger von der Tastatur.
Wir schauen uns jetzt hier oben und habe mal wohl deine auch irgendwie Farbe klar dass die nach einem Server suchen haben Fotos gemacht und haben halt unsere Dortmunder Freunde da halt irgendwie über zwei Stunden,
indem in dem Ding festgehalten auch da wohl oder zumindest da freundlich im Umgang,
aber dann doch wohl auch sehr bestimmt wie im CCC untersuchen wir das jetzt noch gerade was da genau,
geschehen ist und wie wir damit umgehen wieder die rechtliche Situation ist ob dieses Vorgehen von dem Durchsuchungsbeschluss überhaupt gedeckt war oder nicht dazu können wir noch keine.
Finale Aussage treffen aber es war der,
sicherlich bei diesen Leuten war die Polizei falsch und hat glaube ich noch relativ lange,
die sich Zeit gelassen bis sie das dann irgendwann auch mal,
haben wirken lassen dass sie da eindeutig an der falschen Adresse waren also ja nach rechts und links und oben und unten wurde sich da sehr ausführlich umgeschaut.
Ja hoffentlich wird es auch so als wenn die Gelegenheit einfach genutzt wurden also irgendwie der,
Server die wir suchen des Servers oder Beschlagnahmung war der Anlass aber die Danilo hören waren seit 91 nicht mehr im langen august und das war vielleicht die passende Gelegenheit da noch mal.
Welche um zu gucken.
Was wurde denn jetzt noch an an Kollateralschaden angerichtet also du mehrere Server wurden weggenommen oder oder wirklich nur dieser eine.
Soweit wie ich das mitbekommen habe wurde auch noch von free.de Hardware mitgenommen die dafür dass VPN glaube ich zuständig ist genau und unser Server.
Und auf dem Lied er immer auf diese Seite des FSK.
Genau das ist einer der Dinge die da noch drauf die FSK die Webseite sie haben ihren darüber laufen lassen.
Wenn ein andere Projekte für diese auch da Webseiten hatten und so weiter sind da im Ofen.
Was glaubst Du passiert jetzt wer ergibt macht das eben welchen Sinn was was wollte die Polizei wollten die also seid ihr überhaupt in diesem in diesem Ding benannt als als Kollektiv Systemausfall.
Na ich habe mir den Durchsuchungsbeschluss angeguckt und David gegen Unbekannt ermittelt ne also nicht den Grund und alten Gründe stehen da drin es geht darum.
Die Dokumente die veröffentlicht wurden wieder offline zu kriegen und rauszukriegen wer steckt dahinter wer hat die wer hat die veröffentlicht.
Das mit dem offline haben sie natürlich jetzt geschafft fürs erste die werden wahrscheinlich zeitnah irgendwo anders wieder aufpoppen.
Gibt es irgendein Veranlassung davon auszugehen dass man über diesen Server jetzt die Leute findet die die die Seite da betrieben haben.
Sage ich nicht von aus.
Aktivieren in unkonventioneller Dienstleistern irgendwie müssen nicht speichern Videos nicht speichern in du findest auch nicht befinden haben sie haben ja keine Verträge mit den Leuten die unsere Dienste nutzen und anderen genau aufgeschrieben wäre,
under armor.
Das heißt wie macht ihr jetzt weiter.
Wir haben uns gestern Abend nachts zu hingesetzt und versucht die Dienste die davon betroffen sind wieder online zu bringen auf einem alternativ aber das wird erstmal eine Notlösung sein bis wir neue Hardware haben und.
Haben da die geht wieder korrekt ja nicht da drin.
Die kommt dann auch wieder in den langen August.
Da muss doch gar nicht zu ausgetauscht.
Alles klar dann mein wir
wir können hier jetzt noch nicht so viel drüber reden weil das ganze erst gestern geschehen ist laufendes Verfahren großes Durcheinander in in Dortmund.
Aber umso wichtiger ist doch wahrscheinlich an dieser Stelle die Frage die ich bei imo gerade vergessen habe nämlich wie kann man denn da jetzt mal unterstützen.
Ich glaube die konkrete Unterstützung könnte nach Dortmund gehen vom wissenschaftsladen da sind nach deren Aussage mehrere 1000 € Sachschaden entstanden insbesondere die.
Die Eingangstür von Serverräumen dass man eine relative Türe Figur zerstört werden Ursachen glaube ich auch aufgebrochen.
Wenn es um Unterstützung geht den Solidaritätsbekundungen ist glaube ich das Geld in Dortmund an der richtigen Stelle.
Alles klar dann hiermit der Aufruf zur Unterstützung des wissenschaftsladen der seit,
1991 dass das Internet und Vernetzungsprojekt betreibt seit 1996 und eigenen Uplink hat und unter der Domain freigeben,
Internet Dienste für nicht kommerzielle Projekte Gruppen und Privatleute zur Verfügung,
sie stellt und in diesem Rahmen da jetzt gestern eine sehr ruppige und unschöne.
Hausdurchsuchung erfahren musste die gleich noch das gesamte Haus aber heißt ja auch Hausdurchsuchung insofern wird das schon in Ordnung sein in Mitleidenschaft,
gezogen hat Steffen wird uns unser etwas mitgeben.
Also für mich ordnet sich das ein bisschen Indianer Sachen ein die passiert sind ne also wie du suchen bei vielen Freunden die Verschärfung angedachten verschaffen der Polizeigesetze.
Das Know ist irgendwie im Kontext des Ganzen zu betrachten und ja und besondere zu kritisieren.
Absolut gut dass du das sagst weil in ist nicht sogar auch in Dortmund eine Demonstration gegen das neue NRW Polizeigesetz oder ist die nur in Düsseldorf.
Negativ in Düsseldorf.
Düsseldorf ne darf man eigentlich nicht verwechseln die beiden Städte wer zwischen Dortmund und Düsseldorf mal gelebt hat weiß dass das nicht gut ist die beiden zu verwechseln aber jetzt wohne ich ja nicht mehr da deswegen darf ich.
Steffen vielen Dank dass du,
trotzdem ihr gerade echt andere Sorgen und Aufgaben wahrzunehmen habt die Zeit gefunden hast uns mal kurzen Bericht zu zu liefern die es bei euch ausgesehen hat.
Ja gerne ich danke euch für die Möglichkeit das ne.
Gar kein Problem wir hören uns hoffentlich so bald nicht wieder weil alles ja wieder gut wird.
Dala da auf mir drauf.
Alles klar danke dir.
Bis dann ciao.
Ja Steffen Sack glaube ich schon das wichtigste was man hier auch mal abschließend zu diesen Vorfällen sagen muss das ist halt nicht normal ne
das ist das wäre bei einem konventionellen Haus da nicht so passiert das da irgendwie das ganze Haus terrorisiert wird das da die Türen aufgerissen werden und sonstiges jemand dadurch dass man hier,
angemeldet
mit Waffen vor der Tür steht nimmt man sich natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Gelegenheit sowas irgendwie mal normal zu klären z.b. im Sinne von bei jedem anderen Haus da würde in E-Mail eingehen übrigens da gibt's illegale Inhalte und bitte sorgen Sie dafür dass sie sofort weg sind.
Na ja das hat er aber auch was damit zu tun dass normale Oster einfach über das was die eigentlich rechtlich,
dürfen sehr viel mehr speichern aus Sicherheitsgründen weil da könnte ja,
und so weiter das ist dann schon verständlich in Anführungszeichen dass du sagst wenn du jetzt beim Haus da siehst okay der speichert nicht angeblich dann speichert er halt vielleicht doch,
und so weiter aber ich meine hier sowohl free.de ist auch ganz klar ich meine das ist jetzt keine radikale Gruppierungen oder sonst was es ist schon extrem das ist einfach einen Seite 91 bestehende Internetprovider,
der hier irgendwie Dienste anbietet für Wald und Wiesen und alle möglichen Leute und indem sind schon super vergleichbar mit was weiß ich eins und eins und Strato und,
zudem auch immer also das ist schon echt krass.
Ich find's halt mal interessanter wenn du irgendwie soll mich vor kurzem noch mit jemand unterhalten das ist somit mit
Nazi Gruppen auf Facebook auseinandersetzt ne also jetzt wird tatsächlich Nazigruppen ne Sevi auch nicht mehr von Meinungsfreiheit oder Grundgesetz gedeckt und ich warte eigentlich durch will mir ja so dem Moment
den Tag noch so wünschen an dem halt mal die Polizei so bei Facebook ein reitet und sagt hier illegale Inhalte bei euch nur DERPART bei denen passiert das irgendwie,
nicht so wirklich diese Beifänge als als Standard Konzept einer Hausdurchsuchung
die wären ja wirklich also so also was erlaube,
dass sie da irgendwie noch in den Chaos Treff reingehen da der ganz eindeutig sich im im anderen Gebäudeteil befindet der mit denen nichts zu tun hat und dann da halt diese die Menschen mehrere Stunden dort festzusetzen ja.
Der mir noch nicht mal die Anwältin reingelassen,
also das ist schon ein starkes Stück auch zu sagen ok das ganze Gebäude ist jetzt hier abgeriegelt polizeiliche Maßnahme etc und noch nicht mal die Anwältin die da relativ schnell auftauchen konnte Gott sei Dank durfte da rein also.
Wow.
Also da kann ich mir schwer vorstellen dass dass das in irgendeiner Form verhältnismässig ist und die habe da tatsächlich den Eindruck dass da zumindest mit meinem.
Rechtsverständnis.
Einiges nicht in in Einklang zu bringen ist und mit ich hoffe auch mit dem Rechtsverständnis der Bundesrepublik Deutschland einiges nicht in.
Einklang zu bringen S&K ostriv Dortmund,
wurde zumindest nichts weggenommen die Polizei hat sich mehrere Stunden darin aufgehalten hat wie gesagt mehrere Personen die sich im Chaos draft zu dem Zeitpunkt aufgehalten haben dort ja festgehalten.
Die durften auf dem Sofa sitzen und nichts anfassen was ich auch.
Naja man kann sich vorstellen wie das auf Menschen wirkt ne wenn du auf einmal in deinen sicheren räumen,
in der Hand in deinem Hobby und Spaß Projekt wo sich Evoli dich mit anderen begeisterten triffst du auf einmal halt von Polizisten festgehalten wirst so da gibt's natürlich auch keinerlei Politik,
darüber wie was man.
Stefanie wie erfährt warum sie überhaupt geht ne also das müsste das wissen ja wirklich unvorstellbare.
Erlebnisse sein ja da einfach einfach längere Zeit festgehalten zu werden den wurde dann irgendwann wohl auch mal ein Blick in den Durchsuchungsbeschluss gewährt.
Den haben sie aber natürlich nicht ausgehändigt bekommen und dann durften sie auch nicht kopieren was soweit ich weiß eigentlich üblich ist weil natürlich den Polizisten auch klar war dass das was sie da gerade getan haben wohl kaum.
Davon gedeckt ist die werden sich irgendeine Gefahr im Verzug wieder ausdenken warum man jetzt ausgerechnet diese Leute auch noch ein paar Stunden festhalten musste aber,
das geht halt so nicht und es ist wichtig sich gegen diese Vorgehen zu werden wir haben unsere Gesetze dafür.
Das sehe ich alle dran halten auf die Polizei.
Und das genau so etwas nicht passiert und da gibt's nichts dran zu entschuldigen da gibt's nichts von ach ja aber hier mal fünf gerade sein lassen nein das sind genau damit,
unsere Leute nicht.
Der Wilke von Polizei unterliegen damit wir nicht, Tische Erfahrungen machen als unbescholtene Bürger haben wir diese Gesetz sondern sich alle dran zu halten und deswegen bin ich mir relativ sicher dass auch der Graustreif Dortmund da jetzt sehr genau prüfen wird.
Wie damit umzugehen ist.
Das wird sicherlich mit den ganzen Reformen von dem polizeiaufgabengesetz in nur noch viel krasser werden
also wenn ich mir vorstelle ich war da in vier Stunden in der Zelle und ich wusste ok ich
es ist absehbar dass ich hier irgendwann wieder rauskomme als Zeuge Schrägstrich kurzfristig Beschuldigter und so weiter aber das macht mir schon wirklich Angst wenn ich jetzt drüber nachdenke was mit diesen ganzen Reformen möglich ist und was dann sicherlich auch wieder in solchen Fällen unsere Szene betreffen werden,
wir treffen wird und das ist schon echt da stellen sich die Nackenhaare auf.
Das wollte ich auch gerade noch anmerken und das war jetzt in NRW und da ist jetzt noch kein neues Polizeigesetz so also und man sieht wie wie jetzt da schon in die Rechtsbeugung gegangen wird.
Das wird dann sicherlich nicht besser,
von daher hier noch mal der Hinweis wäre es noch nicht gemerkt hat NRW ist da auch in der Gefahr eine bayerische.
Freie Zone zu werden.
Wer eine Verschlimmbesserung nach bayrischer Art zu erhalten und der vielleicht ganz angemessen dass ihr da mal eure abgeordnet.
Damals schon genug dafür war ja noch irgendwie was ich diesen Zusammenhang mit diesem Endlager.
Muss noch hierhin schöne Aktion.
Ja sie in um den um den politischen Zusammenhang hier noch mal ein bisschen auszuweiten also es geht ging bei diesem.
Bei dieser Maßnahme um Gegner des geplanten französischen Atommüll-Endlager.
Da gibt's also eine eine da wollen sie hat jetzt einen einen einen Speicher bauen für also ein Endlager für,
Atommüll
120 km von der deutschen Grenze entfernt ursprünglich war dieser Ort als Forschungseinrichtung geplant inzwischen haben sie ein aber zum Endlager gemacht also vergleicht man dass man quasi mit Zünder Gorleben Situation ne,
Zwischenlager Endlager Forschung hast du nicht gesehen hochacker sind die Wert auf einmal da so ne.
Es gibt da durchaus ordentlichen Widerstand Besetzung Mitte Juni von französischen Aktivisten der jetzt auch irgendwie so ein Video auf YouTube gefunden wo wo Greenpeace ein.
Eine Drohne.
Ein Drohnen Flugzeug gebaut hat was er aussieht wie Superman und das Ding halt irgendwie gegen einen gegen das Atomkraftwerk,
im Bouquet oder ich mache mein Goethe mein Französisch ist so alt im Budget die sind auf jeden Fall mit der Drohne gegen so ein AKW geflogen um zu zeigen hast das AKW nicht allzu sicher ist.
Wie schreibt sich das BGE.
Ja und da weiß ja nicht wie man wie man.
Boogie würde ich sagen.
Ja also auf jeden Fall Greenpeace ist auch wieder eindrucksvoll unterwegs so sehr interessant dieses AKW gegen dass sie damit ihren Superman fliegen scheint jetzt echt nicht so weit in den Karpaten zu stehen.
Also in diesem Zusammenhang stand also diese Untersuchung.
Bei Systemausfall und es gibt hier Medienberichte aus denen hervorgeht dass wohl auf dem beschlagnahmten Server sich.
Dokumente befunden befinden haben könnten die nicht für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmt sind und unter Umständen aus einem hacking Angriff in diesem.
Anti AKW Zusammenhang Stamm können.
Ich würde aber mal abschließend weil wir uns jetzt so viel über Hausdurchsuchung unterhalten haben und weil ich.
Merke das natürlich aus Versuchung.
Gerade wie man diesen Beispiel sieht nicht immer Menschen treffen die darauf vorbereitet sind also auch das was er jetzt hier in der Sendung gesagt hat er ist halt jemand der sich,
lange Zeit mit dem Gedanken auseinander gesetzt hat dass so etwas mal passieren könnte und ich kann nur sagen dass sich das sehr lohnt,
sich mit diesem Gedanken mal auseinandergesetzt zu haben.
Sei es nur indem man dafür sorgt dass die eigenen Rechner mit ordentlicher Festplattenverschlüsselung ausgestattet sind dass man sich unter Umständen darüber Gedanken macht was für Objekte.
Und Substanzen in der eigenen Wohnung oder im Hackerspace aufbewahrt werden.
Aber auch dass man sich mit dem Prozess generell,
auseinandersetzt hat gerade schon gesagt die kommen zwischen zwischen zwei Zehen zwischen 22 Uhr und 4 Uhr oder 5 Uhr seid ihr sicher in den eigenen vier Wänden der dürfen sie nicht kommen,
ja aber danach muss aufgeräumt werden ja sie sind gerne mal auch freundlich dient dann aber natürlich,
DM
den verwickeln in ein Gespräch vielleicht verplappert sich da ja jemand ne so das passiert dann sehr gerne das ist also auch scheinbar völlig egal Edingen erlischt irgendein Heft auf der Zeil,
Magazin auf dem Tisch dann guckt halt der Polizist da drauf und dann hast du den schon gelesen den Artikel oder früher haben wir immer als wir immer auf dem Schulhof gekifft oder irgend so ein Scheiß halt nicht mal die die einigen können einige können's besser andere können es nicht so gut
und man hat gerne mal so Situationen dass wir jetzt auch hier bei dieser Tafel scheinbar.
Wirklich jetzt Sachen wo man echt nicht damit rechnet dass die ein jemals Probleme machen würden z.b. hatte ich in meiner Wohnung das Schild Vorsicht bissiger Hund an einer Tür.
Da hat der Polizist hat eine klare gezogen und hat geschrieben wo ist der Hund wo ist der Hund das ist also so,
man kann sich das manchmal nicht ausmalen in was für verrückte Situation man sich bringt werde halt irgendwie jemand in den Space kommt unten
f-bomb benannt,
Lack ausdruckt oder was auch sonst ist viel passiert es ist natürlich kein Buttplug und ihr seid alle eingeladen mit dem Rucksack auf YouTube kann man sich das Video von den Dingern in Aktion Anschauen des Videos auf jeden Fall.
Jugendfrei.
Pfefferwerk also sich da ein Gespräche zu verwickeln zu lassen ist er nicht empfohlen auch irgendwas zu unterschreiben außer euren eigenen Widerspruch gegen alles was sie getan haben.
Keinesfalls wenn ich da irgendwas unter die Nase gehalten wird ihr seid in einer Situation in der ihr.
Schockiertheit und Angst hab.
Wir können das auch mal ganz konkret sagen also bei uns gab es dann sicherstellungsprotokoll da war teilweise schon das ja ich bin damit einverstanden angekreuzt,
und die haben nur gesagt hier bitte unterschreiben also da werden dann,
sozusagen alle Mittel und Wege genutzt dir irgendwie was unterzuschieben dass du die Durchsuchungen freiwillig erlaubt hast dass du die Gegenstände freiwillig aufgibst
und so weiter nein da musst du überall nein angekreuzt werden und man ist nie damit einverstanden auch wenn man sich jetzt nicht wert
dagegen also werden hilft doch eh nichts mehr aber zumindest dass diese Dokumentation angeht klarstellen nein ich war nicht mit der Durchsuchung einverstanden nein ich bin mit der Beschlagnahme nicht einverstanden nicht sich was unterschieben lassen
also die kommen wirklich mit vor ausgefüllten Formularen an.
Was auf Freitag nach Hausdurchsuchung und Montag wird die Waschmaschine geliefert.
Es lohnt sich z.b. auch von den einschlägigen Organisationen die sich regelmäßig mit sowas auseinandersetzen einfach mal die Radgeber in der Nähe der Tür aufzubewahren,
SH euch allen gewünscht dass sie die nie braucht,
und dass die einfach nur Staub fangen aber wenn ihr sie braucht dann seid ihr halt froh dass ihr dann nämlich mal ganz kurz den standardablauf durchgehen können der nämlich lautet,
Mode hat gerade schon gesagt Ruhe bewahren.
Und vertraute Person anrufen die Anwälte oder Anwältin und Beobachter hinschicken soll meistens dürfen Beobachter nicht rein,
also jetzt in Dortmund z.b. nicht bei euch wurde das ja sogar angeboten so oder so können Sie als können Sie unter Umständen als Zeugen dienen oder euch auch einfach nur mal Support leisten dass ihr euch in diesen vielen Stunden,
nicht alleine fühlt möglichst sofort die Informationen in Erfahrung bringen was da überhaupt los ist also,
gegen wen richtet sich der Durchsuchungsbeschluss was ist der Grund für den Durchsuchungsbeschluss den wir mal also sehen wenn man genau durchlesen sich eine Kopie davon geben lassen Mann will den Namen und die Dienstnummer,
der,
Einsatzleiterin haben und es gibt dann auch in den Vorträgen von Udo Vetter ich hatte ja gerade schon genannt 23 C3 sie haben das Recht zu schweigen legendärer,
Vortrag vom Schaf Rechtsanwalt Judo Judo Udo Vetter der auch das lawblog unterhält als jemand der sich damit jeden Tag auseinandersetzt der z.b. aussagt wenn da die Suche nach einem spezifischen Objekt ist.
Dann kann es unter Umständen sich anbieten,
dieses eine spezifische Objekt eben auch auszuhändigen weil damit ist die Maßnahme beendet und man möchte nämlich nicht dass da irgendwelche Zufallsfunde passieren wie dass man noch im,
wie steht das hier bei Udo Vetter so schön im Nachttisch das eine oder andere rauchutensil,
gefunden wird weil wenn das passiert wenn diese Sachen in diesem Rahmen festgestellt werden
dann dürfen die natürlich auch Teil eines Ermittlungsverfahren werden da ist sie meine US-amerikanisch geprägte Schulbildung anders gewesen da konnte man zumindest wenigstens sagen Nase bei der Durchsuchung wenn jetzt irgendwie,
ein Objekt gesucht wird das eine bestimmte Größe hat das jede Schublade wo das nicht nach menschlichem Ermessen nicht reinpasst,
z.b. Atombombe passt einfach nicht in der Schublade dass man daneben sagt diese dieses Gerät nicht öffnen aber da glaube ich das ist in Deutschland
nicht unbedingt so denn Gründe irgendetwas zu öffnen.
Lassen sich immer konstruieren das heißt nein will die einen nicht so schnell wie möglich aus der Bude raus Halle haben Widerspruch einlegen und protokollieren lassen.
Das ist das einzige was man selber unterschreibt und auch die Beamtinnen unterschreiben sollen denn durch diesen Widerspruch dürfen sie dann nicht mehr schriftliche Aufzeichnungen,
durchlesen dürfen lediglich sichten und müssen die dann versiegeln dass es genau das dass Moritz jetzt wegen der wegen des Gefahr im Vollzug,
was deckt er später machen konnte lohnt sich immer das sofort zu verlangen zu sagen ich widerspreche dieser Maßnahme deswegen versiegeln bis wir das vor Gericht geklärt haben was ihr getan.
Wenn ihr in einer WG wohnt.
Gibt es natürlich auch Grenzen dafür welche Räume die betreten dürfen also grundsätzlich dürfen die nur in die Räume,
der Betroffenen oder also der Betroffenen und dann in Gemeinschaftsräume wie Küche Bad und so weiter in die Zimmer eurer Mitbewohner nicht jetzt ist das natürlich so ein bisschen ne wenn man jetzt ein Ehepaar ist,
dann wird davon ausgegangen dass es keine,
Trennung der Räume gibt Kinderzimmer dürfen sie nicht rein es sei denn es ist eindeutig dass ihr in diesem Kinderzimmer,
auch euren Tätigkeiten nachgeht.
Man sollte auf jeden Fall verlangen dass nur unter Beobachtung durch die Beschuldigte oder deren vertraute durchsucht wird die parallelisieren nämlich sonst gerne Ihre Suche,
na und dann habt ihr die auf einmal unbewacht in irgendwelchen Räumen müsste euch nachher darüber Gedanken machen.
Was dir denn da tun der Zauber Begriff ist hier ein von euch Bevollmächtigter Zeuge.
Das war auch in der Tat so dass sie sozusagen so ein bisschen abgewartet haben ob ob mir das klar ist dass ich da dabei sein darf und dann habe ich auch wirklich drauf geachtet dass keinerlei Maßnahmen in der Wohnung stattfinden außer ich bin da dabei.
Das ist z.b. auch irgendwie was was mir nicht so ganz klar ist also diese diese Rechtsbelehrung Nader
die wird natürlich von der Polizei nicht geliefert na ich weiß wie gesagt ich habe das in in die USA damals gelernt da gibt's ja natürlich wieder diese Punkte welche Rechte man hat dass man eine Rechtsbelehrung bekommen muss sieht man ja auch immer in den Serien die imbery dass die Leute
mirandized werden als ihre Miranda rechte vorgelesen bekommen benannt nach dem Fall,
vorhin gesagt wollte sie haben das Recht zu schweigen ja der Film überhaupt mal gesagt du musst kannst auch mal nichts sagen.
Doch das ist dann passiert kurz bevor wir in die Zellen gestopft werden.
Ja
Als Beschuldigte was da unsere Rechte sind.
Genau da hat sich ja euer Status auch geändert.
Also keine Gespräche keine Aussagen keine Unterschriften Zeugen mit dabei haben Widerspruch einlegen gegen alles was sie tun.
Und dann natürlich während die Durchsuchung stattfindet ordentlich lauern ja also in der Regel überschreiten Sie Ihre Kompetenzen gehen in Räume in diese eigentlich nicht rein dürfen.
Da muss natürlich Widerspruch eingelegt werden Mann verlangt die Versiegelung von Papieren und Notizen sodass sie nur der Staatsanwalt anschaut und ihr habt auch keine Mitwirkungspflicht was auch immer das heißen mag,
wenn dann nachher die Tür kaputt ist.
Also der typische Trick ist wirklich hart dürfen bei der mal reinschauen oder allein schon an der Tür wir haben hier ein Durchsuchungsbeschluss dürfen wir mal reinkommen nein
ja ihr könnt es rechtlich aber ihr dürft hier meiner Meinung nach nicht also das sind lauter so sprachliche Spielereien wo man auch ein bisschen drauf achten sollte.
Psychologischer Trick na wenn Polizist fragt kann ich kann ich mir das mal angucken der ist natürlich ne,
eine Autorität dahinter und man weiß nicht dass man da nein sagen kann erstens weiß man es rechtlich
vielleicht nicht und zweitens hat man es auch aus der Freundlichkeit der Situation weiß man es nicht aber auf dem Papier schaut nachher ein Richter und da steht,
6 Polizisten sagen übereinstimmend dass der dass der Beschuldigte Erlaubnis erteilt hat.
Diese Tür einzutreten oder ins Schlafzimmer zu gehen und unterm Bett zu.
Kleine Nachfrage diese Versiegelung was ist das technisch dann also wodurch wird.
Aus der Tüte und das wird mit Tape zugeklebt ich weiß es nicht genau aber ja es wird halt zumindest rechtlich sichergestellt ob technisch das soweit sichergestellt wird.
Würde davon ausgehen dass die.
Es wird irgendwie versiegelt die haben halt irgendwelche Siegel ja so Plastik Klebesiegel diese nicht so leicht wieder abnehmbar sind Aufkleber.
Aufkleber.
Wenn sie dann irgendwann fertig sind durchsuchungs und beschlagnahmeprotokoll verlangen.
Und da habt ihr dann auch Zeit die haben sich stundenlang Zeit genommen euren Räumen,
die hat jetzt Zeit dass du so ein Protokoll in Ruhe zu prüfen und auch wenn nicht beschlagnahmt wo du musst das da stehen ja
und er muss auch nachher sein dass es das war's jetzt ja und die Beamten und deren Zeuginnen müssen das unterschreiben nicht hier.
Wird das ist der Klassiker ja schon über das habe ich alles mitgenommen unterschreiben Sie mal eben dass das richtig ist ne nee das könnt ihr mal selber unterschreiben ihr können natürlich vorher kontrollieren ob das stimmt.
Und dann eben auch sehr wichtig nachdem das passiert ist möglichst schnell ein Gedächtnisprotokoll schreiben ziemlich genau was es da passiert welche Uhrzeiten welche Fragen welche Räume.
Also alleine aus dem
Volksbildung as Volksbildung suspect also ihr werdet sicherlich viel miterleben was man nachher durchaus auch noch positiv war arbeiten kann und auch Leuten weitergeben kann als als
a-ok da habe ich mich vielleicht bisschen falsch verhalten a-ok das haben sie nicht so richtig genau durchsucht und so weiter macht euch da notizen aber natürlich vor allem zu den Sachen wo ihr seid da waren eigentlich irgendwie so Grenzüberschreitungen da.
Und das geht dann zur Anwältin und die kümmert sich drum Schadensbilanz erstellen auch das natürlich ein krasse krasses.
Fotos machen wenn irgendwie was war.
Und dann auch sich mal darüber Gedanken machen dass eine Hausdurchsuchung kommt selten allein was gab es unter Umständen noch für Maßnahmen die.
Bei dem Verdacht der da im Raum steht wo eben zu dieser Maßnahme der Hausdurchsuchung.
Immerhin schon mal ein Staatsanwalt unten Richter oder eine Richterin überzeugt werden konnten.
Was für Maßnahmen sind.
Haben sich unter Umständen doch auch angeboten und da ist eben der Telekommunikationsüberwachung und hat Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachung in der Regel auch eine naheliegende Maßnahme je nachdem.
Auch eine Raumüberwachung.
Das ist eben das kommt natürlich darauf an da gibt's da so großer Lauschangriff sind ja nur bestimmte bei bestimmten schweren Dilly.
Also wenn wenn wir jetzt noch mal das Szenario openlab nehmen mit irgendwie Sprengstoff Vorbereitung Anschlag und so weiter und wir dürfen eben irgendwie 5 Stunden nachdem also
gleich nach Beendigung der Maßnahmen dort,
die in Abwesenheit von jeglichen Personen passiert ist wieder die Räume nutzen und gleichzeitig sind beide Verfahren immer noch gegen Unbekannt offen dann ist davon auszugehen dass die Ermittlungsmaßnahmen eben noch andauern.
Also nicht nicht gleich wenn die Tür zu klappt so ein Scherz Reisen mit ja Gott sei Dank hat sie nicht die richtige Bombe gefunden.
Also die sind auch nicht sehr Humor Verständnis.
Ja ja eben aber das ist gerade der Nerd Humor entspannt sich ja über Sarkasmus das ist das was ich meine.
Naturista ganz schlecht da habe ich auch mal zwei blaue Augen für kassiert weil ich zum Inhalt meiner Tasche befragt wurde und dann auch eine Nerd Humor Antwort gegeben habe und das war.
Keine gute Idee.
Nee war gar nicht so gut.
Stellt euch wirklich drauf ein das sind alles sehr träge Prozesse die Menschen dann auch wenn man zum Verhör ist die können ihre Computer nicht bedienen die Drucker funktionieren nicht das ist eine technische Hölle die man,
sozusagen kaum mit ertragen kann,
ich habe dann denen eben auch sonst Sarkasmus Kommentar geliefert von wegen das ist Zermürbungstaktik was jetzt hier gerade stattfindet das ist es nicht sondern das ist wirklich so ihr müsst da irgendwie macht meditative Übungen,
bereitet euch darauf vor eben Atemübungen und so weiter weil das wird alles sehr viel länger dauern als es eigentlich nach gesunden Menschenverstand dauern sollte sowas.
Klingt ein bisschen als ob man da sowas vielleicht auch mal üben sollte so bisschen sowieso ein Feuer Übungen.
Ja ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt irgendwie in das ist ja schon fast zur Militärübungen da bin ich ja überhaupt kein Fan von den aber wir könnten natürlich eigentlich so gegenseitig unangekündigt in andere Hackerspaces kommen und das ganze mal,
sozusagen vielleicht wäre das ganz nett.
Guten Tag Ausflug.
Ja das ist nicht so abwegig genau das ist nicht so abwegig.
Was ist ein dies ist keine Übung aber das wäre also sich damit auseinanderzusetzen ist.
Die beste Methode ist sowas realistisch nachzuspielen warm und man muss ja nicht so tun als wäre es echt aber dass man quasi mal von übten Leuten.
Branchenintern.
Spielerisch sozusagen die Situation herbeiführt wie sie vermutlich ablaufen könnte und.
Aber auch unangekündigt dann vielleicht noch mit irgendwem abgesprochen in dem Space aber die meisten dürfen es nicht wissen so.
Unangekündigt vielleicht zumindest was die genaue Zeit.
Wenn wir gleich noch den ICE nehmen ne dann schaffen wir es bis morgen um 6 Uhr und RaumZeitLabor.
Schnallt euch schon mal an.
Ja aber ich meine so so so könnte man halt solche Situationen einfach mal trainieren und da auch ein anderes Bewusstsein dafür schaffen weil naja also bei der Dichter unserer schlechten Nachrichten hier.
Also wo ich nicht.
Das war wo ich rechtlich eben nicht so genau Bescheid wusste und was glaube ich wirklich relevant ist auch für jetzt die Sachen die bei uns wahrscheinlich in unseren Szenen relevant ist es eben genau diese Zeugen Geschichte,
aber nicht als Beschuldigter geführt wird dann kommen sie erstmal schon an der Tür heben und sagen ja ja nur Zeuge und so dass man da eben bereitwilliger ist vielleicht irgendwie sich verwickeln zu lassen in Gespräche,
und ist ja nur Zeuge und so weiter es ist so dass da gibt's auch ein schöner Artikel auf dem lawblog zu zu der rechtlichen Lage bei Zeugen und die ist leider miserabel,
also als Zeuge hat man inzwischen das ist eine Gesetzesänderung von 2017 die Verpflichtung auszusagen dann hat die Verpflichtung alles zu sagen was man weiß,
man hat nicht die Möglichkeit einer Zeugenbefragung nicht mehr teilzunehmen das war bis dato war das so du konntest als Zeuge einfach sagen ja nee ich bin kein Zeuge.
Das geht nicht mehr also da gibt's schon ganz krasse Maßnahmen die man gegen Zeugen fahren kann und man kann die in diesen Status auch relativ schnell dann geändert bekommen.
Wenn es nicht sogar mal in der Sendung.
Ja das haben wir behandelt.
Thematisiert nagen aufrecht Cordelia noch mal raussuchen.
Also insbesondere dann wenn halt irgendwie in das Beschluss dabei ist dann hat man eben keine Wahl mehr und man hat auch im Nachhinein als Anwälte relativ wenig Handhabe,
z.b. gibt's ja wenn du Beschuldigter bist zumindest eine Möglichkeit Daten Einsicht für die Anwälte das gibt's für Zeugen nicht.
Also das ist schon auch noch mal was von man vielleicht.
Also ich meine sagen.
Trag braucht zu diesem vorbereiten auf Hausdurchsuchung ist dieser Zeugen Aspekt.
Ja sagen was man weiß und ich meine wie wie machen die Profis dass die sagen dann immer mir ist mir ist es nicht erinnerlich.
Ja gut es gibt ein Spektrum von realitäts Darstellungen in die man sich dann da begeben kann ich denke wenn es jetzt gerade umso Hausding Sachen geht und und ebenso was Wieczorek Sitz und so weiter,
da bin ich eigentlich auch in Absprache mit vielen Anwälten wo ich da bisher drüber gesprochen habe ein großer Fan geworden von von,
zu wissen dass es eine Masche ist zu wissen es Masche ist dass sie einen Gespräche verwickeln wollen und so weiter und trotzdem sehr ausgiebig und ausführlich,
da darstellen warum man den Rechtsstaat sehr gerne hat warum man seine Rechte wahrnimmt und eben auch nicht zustimmt aber durchaus bereit ist als Zeuge
dazu auszusagen und zu sagen nein wir haben keine Logs nein und so weiter wir haben damit nichts zu tun und es auch klar darstellt weil sonst zieht sich die Sache halt ewig hin eher unabhängig jetzt davon ob man die Hardware wieder haben will oder nicht,
aber halt einfach grundsätzlich bin ich schon in Freund des Rechtsstaates und da dazu beizutragen dass sie relativ schnell feststellen ok die Maßnahme muss beendet werden,
hat schon auch Vorteile also wir hatten viele Verfahren die halt relativ schnell jetzt bei dem Tor exit Geschichten mit der Auskunft ja wir haben keine Daten und dann ist das irgendwie geringfügige ebaybetrug oder sowas versucht da,
wird das halt einfach eingestellt und dass das glaube ich von Vorteil für alle.
Und aber das ist halt eine Abwägung Sache da sollte man sich schon mental vorbereiten wenn man solche Projekte betreibt.
Gerade wenn man solche Projekte betreibt dann ist das glaube ich mit diesem Typen jetzt nicht nur so daher gesagt nicht jeder
der mal im Hackerspace übernachtet hat muss jetzt gleich das Schlimmste befürchten aber geht halt wenn man irgendeiner Form kritische Infrastruktur für andere betreibt
oder auch für sich selber sollte man vielleicht mal das Ding vom Ende her dick.
So viel Untersuchung und Festnahmen einer Mahnung.
Eine Festnahme haben wir noch.
Die tickt aber schon zurück.
Die liegt einige Zeit zurück aber und hat einen Spendenaufruf von Peter steudtner erreichte Peter steudtner na ja der,
Trainer für Gewaltfreie Kommunikation und Internetsicherheit da der in der Türkei.
Festgenommen wurde vor einiger Zeit.
Ja ja das war unter dem.
Berichtete.
Verkitten oder irgendwie sowas.
Genau er ist seit neun Monaten frys bei seiner Familie und seinen Freunden.
Angekommen hatte viel Zeit mit Familie und Freund verbracht Pressearbeit arbeitet jetzt langsam wieder und möchte einige Dinge wieder aufnehmen die,
ihm wichtig sind,
für die weitere Aufarbeitung aber auch für den produktiven Umgang mit dem was ihm da passiert ist.
Der war ja Nummer mehrere Monate da halt weckewerk nackt in der Türkei und.
Deswegen möchte er jetzt sich ab dem 57.de hat der erste Jahrestag der Verhaftung war also es ist ziemlich genau ein Jahr her dass er verhaftet wurde.
Auf paar Sachen konzentrieren bisschen Arbeit leisten und würde gerne 75% seiner Arbeitskraft auf verschiedene Bereiche,
konzentrieren einmal mit den anderen Leuten zusammenarbeiten die eben den andauerndem Prozess in der Türkei da immer noch haben er würde gerne eine Handreichung preparing for prison.
Erarbeiten im auch unter seinen Fokus im Umgang mit Menschen wie kann man sich im Gefängnis.
Engagieren wie kann man sich darauf vorbereiten die kann man da solidarisch sein für familienanwälte und Unterstützern spezieller Fokus auf das Aufarbeiten der Erfahrung die sie eben als Menschenrecht.
Verteidiger in diesem Bereich gemacht haben.
Oder möchte sich gerne mit verschiedenen kreativen Medien unter anderem einem Dokumentarfilm mit einer Ausstellung sein,
eigenen Erfahrungen auch der Solidarität der erfahren hat wildman finde das ist sehr wichtig dass man so etwas nicht einfach vergisst,
und das wäre gerade in Deutschland wo die jetzt über die Wiederwahl Erdogans irgendwie mehr oder weniger nebenbei berichtet und dass wir nicht vergessen was auch unsere.
Leute in diesen Ländern erfahren haben deswegen hat er einen Spendenaufruf in die Welt gesetzt der von der KURVE Wustrow umgesetzt wird und ich denke das Essen.
Sehr unterstützend fetter Grund und deswegen möchte ich euch vorschlagen euch das mal anzuschauen den Link findet ihr in den.
Shownotes bei könnt ihr in dieser Sendung Peter steudtner finanziell unterstützen ihr könnt.
Der in den Wissenschaft Laden Dortmund unterstützen und auch die zwiebelfreunde haben wie Moritz im Vorgespräch sagt jetzt schon irgendwie,
2000 € kosten allein gehabt durch diesen Besuch und wird sicherlich noch einiges mehr kommen und da ist Solidarität und finanzielle Unterstützung einfach mal von Nöten,
in solchen Zeiten müssen wir zusammenhalten und damit sind wir bei.
Raschelt nervös mit der Tastatur wo ist das Soundboard im wir sind bei den Omega hast du den Knopf wo ist er denn wir sind bei den Terminen.
Am 7.07 finden in Berlin,
Zwickau Leipzig München und anderen Städten Aktionen der
Seebrücke Stadt die Seebrücke ist eine internationale Bewegung aus der Zivilbevölkerung und sie fordert sichere Fluchtwege und eine Entkriminalisierung der Seenotrettung.
Und am 21. September gibt's wieder eine neue Ausgabe von das ist Netzpolitik die Veranstaltung mit dem merkwürdigen Namen von unseren Freunden von Netzpolitik
. org ursprünglich war das mal zum Feiern des Jubiläums mittlerweile eine feste Veranstaltung,
das kleinste eines politischen Zehner 21 September in Berlin
in der Volksbühne und der Vorverkauf ist jetzt gestartet.
Nicht nur auf dem CCC Congress habt ihr von der juventa gehört dem Schiff zur Seenotrettung darüber gibt es jetzt einen Film,
und diese Premiere wurde auf dem Filmfest in Bologna mit einem Word ausgezeichnet und ist jetzt in
vielen Städten in Deutschland zu sehen am 97 in Berlin am 10.07 in Leipzig am 12.07 in Berlin am 3.10 17 Berlin am 19.7 in Magdeburg die Liste ist lang der Film ist eine,
Empfehlung und da könnt ihr mal ins Kino gehen bei diesem schönen Wetter.
Und wenn es einfach mal wieder so zum Hacken ruft für den wäre vielleicht V bis 7. Oktober in Hannover das richtige denn da gibt's,
head over findet statt in der Bürgerschule Nordstadt in Hannover und deshalb klassisches geekend mit Hack Center Vorträgen etc.pp,
Stadt seit dem 1. Juli gibt's den Vorverkauf und auch da bitte mitmachen.
Und damit wären wir durch ne na also ich wollte noch heute noch ein YouTube-Video empfehlen.
Hahaha ein YouTube-Video.
Video bei Media CCC de und waren wir bei der Fusion.
Kleine Musikfestival im am Rande Berlins,
eine kleine wenn ein Dreikampf der Kommunikationsguerilla ausgerichtet da ist das Zentrum für politische Schönheit das ja hier schon öfter Thema war gegen das
Peng Kollektiv angetreten das ja hier auch schon öfter Thema war und auch in dieser Sendungen verstecktes Thema war
da gibt es also eine eher haben wir einen Dreikampf ausgerechnet in drei Disziplinen haben wir Stefan Pelzer und John Peters gegeneinander,
antreten lassen und ich glaube das ist ein ganz amüsantes Aufeinandertreffen geworden das natürlich nicht allzu ernst genommen werden sollte und nach all unseren ernsten Themen habe ich mir gedacht empfehle ich mal was witziges.
Ja das stimmt das kann man nicht so leicht ja lange Sendung wichtiger Anlass.
Moritz vielen Dank.
Dass Du den Weg zu uns gefunden hast und hier wird die aktuelle Lage berichtet hast das war jetzt mal eine richtig schöne Hausdurchsuchung Sendung muss auch mal sein,
ja vielleicht noch ein Hinweis hier in der Metaebene fängt jetzt ein bisschen diese Sommerpause an Logbuch Netzpolitik,
soll davon nicht ganz so sehr betroffen sein.
Und wir werden so gut es geht Sendung machen aus der Ferne und schauen ansonsten gibt's noch ein bisschen Resteverwertung und vor aufgenommene Sendung ihr müsst also nicht komplett leiden sondern so ein bisschen.
Scheiße wirklich glaube ich gewisse mal eben hin.